All
right man,
we're live all of a sudden.
Thanks for having me,
man.
Thanks for being here.
Yeah,
this is cool.
This is cool.
Any friend of Duncan's a friend of mine.
Likewise.
It's cool.
It's fun,
Dude.
Okay,
so I have to ask the opening question.
What the fuck is it like being the son
of Timothy Leary?
The opening question,
right?
It has to be the has to be.
Okay.
That's cool.
Um,
yeah man,
you know,
and you know that the answer to the
question kind of,
it's changed a lot over the course of
time obviously,
you know,
because when I was younger,
when I was a kid,
you know,
really up until my mid twenties,
even my late twenties,
I would say like,
I didn't know how to answer that
question.
How could I,
it's just all I knew was just life,
you know,
it's just my dad.
It's just how I grew up,
you know,
he would take me to little league,
he'd make sure I did my homework or
didn't do my homework in my case,
but whatever it was,
you know what I mean?
It just was a life,
I didn't have any objectivity to it.
I didn't have any distance from it.
I couldn't be remote from it,
you know,
I didn't know like that.
It was perhaps really strange.
And then,
uh,
you know,
he,
he died in [inaudible] 96.
I was 22 and then kind of after that
then I sort of,
you know,
I got some distance from it.
Then I was like,
Oh shit,
you know,
things were a little different at home,
they were.
Well,
your dad is probably like one of the
most important,
if not the most important people ever in
terms of the psychedelic revolution.
He was,
I mean,
yeah.
My relationship with him and my
relationship,
especially with his work was um,
yeah,
I mean of course the sexuality part was
a core pillar and I understood that's
what made him famous,
but I considered him to be like,
he was a futurist really,
you know,
when,
during my formative years.
I mean,
the psychedelic thing was always there,
but he was much more interested in like,
in technology and cyber culture and kind
of like the progressive kind of
technology,
arts and things like that.
And uh,
you know,
in the eighties he called,
uh,
the,
the PC,
the lsd of the eighties,
you know,
so he was kind of really shifting and I
kind of considered him by somebody who
just had the innate ability to
constantly reinvent themselves.
And of course the psychedelics were,
you know,
were the core and I guess probably is
also probably a big part of how we can
reinvent themselves.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
that,
that's,
that's true.
I mean,
well,
and considering,
I mean,
you can relate with this I think too.
And you know,
he didn't do his first second delek
until he was 40.
Oh Wow.
You were,
what,
30 or something,
right?
Yeah.
So it's a similar,
like you're well into your adult life
and you're well formed.
You have an identity.
That's Jack Harris story too.
Oh,
is Jack Hara?
Was a goldwater republican like deep
into his,
uh,
again,
I think he was getting divorced.
I met,
uh,
met a young gal and she turned them onto
the weed and all of a sudden he was
like,
Hey,
what the fuck have I been missing?
Yeah,
he's still
at,
to this day is still the strongest we'd
have ever had Jack Harris trained.
Fuck man.
He was a cool guy,
man.
He was a bum me out when he left.
Yeah,
he did good work.
So your dad probably would have had an
amazing time with what's going on today
in terms of virtual reality and the
integration of cell phones into our life
and an almost inescapable way.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's funny like the vr thing where just
jamie and I were just talking about it
before we rolled tape,
um,
you know,
we were doing vr,
like,
you know,
we were at the NASA Ames research
center.
People were like,
Jaron Lanier.
And we're like,
really?
Um,
uh,
you know,
journaling.
There was kind of the godfather of vr
and he was bringing kind of setup store
house in the early nineties.
And like really early,
kind of almost eight bit rudimentary Vr,
but it was there.
So like what did that look like?
It kind of looks like I'm being an
inside of an Atari video game.
So real pixelated,
pixelated,
eight bit kind of Clunky,
blocked like,
but with full three dimensionality and
stuff like that.
Did you ever see loved it?
Duncan's Oculus the first day of the
first versions that he had,
which was kind of like that real kind of
pixelated.
Was it similar to that and very similar
to that?
Yeah.
And you had a Duncan and I went on the
show together and didn't go gunters
university.
It's Vr chat show and you know,
this was recent and you know,
it's still,
vr is still kind of in that,
you know,
how does that work?
Like does someone have a Vr headset on
another location and then you guys both
enter the same room.
So you're in the room together.
You.
Yeah.
Well Dunk and I actually we're in the
same room together.
We happen to be but yeah.
And then all of these people with
different headsets on and then everybody
has a different avatar and they're all
in that room with you.
They're all in the room.
Was very cool,
very cool.
But I like that one.
Um,
I think the servers crashed 20 people.
Oh,
how many people can it support?
Uh,
what we had.
Maybe like a thousand I think.
But yeah,
I like to get beyond that.
You need some Pr.
I mean the avatars,
you know,
they're pretty involved.
They're pretty,
you know,
they made me into this Hari Krishna monk
or some shit,
like the psychedelic clown.
It was pretty cool.
But yeah,
you know,
my dad load field and we were,
he was,
it was right near.
He'd love it.
It'd be really cool.
Yeah.
I've always thought about him and I'm
Mckenna.
Mckenna obviously was a big futurist as
well and completely fascinated by the
possibilities and where technology was
going out of love to see those guys
today.
Just take this all in and try to.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Right?
Like terrence was writing about the
connection between psilocybin in virtual
reality.
Right?
I mean,
that's the subtext of not food,
of the gods,
but if I'm one of those nations,
no,
it wasn't that one.
I'm filing which ones,
what it's called mushrooms,
virtual reality and you know,
and he really saw the connection between
and you know,
there is no accident that the
godfather's the true visionaries of the
Silicon Valley Movement.
We're kind of remnants from the 60,
you know,
Steve Jobs,
archaic,
revival,
revival.
Yeah.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's right.
Um,
yeah.
He also,
terrance also had this idea that you
would be able to recreate the DMT world
in virtual reality and you'd be able to
experience what people see when they're
on dmt without actually taking the drug.
He believed that there was going to come
a time when technology was so good and
the images that you could create would
be so elaborate that you literally could
create the DMT images.
I couldn't believe what I'm kind of.
I'm kind of leaning there right now
myself,
you know,
I mean we kind of a,
again,
Duncan,
you know,
we kind of had this crackpot idea of
taking a,
a Vr into the flotation tank,
into the float tank with this kind of in
mind that by disassociating the body and
kind of getting rid of it because you
know,
what's the big dmt thing is it's the
disassociated.
If you just leave Joe,
you leave Zach and you become whatever.
So by taking the vr masks it a headset
into the tank.
Maybe combining the two worlds that
could.
I don't know,
I'm still bullish on that.
I think it could work.
I think Sarah says,
right?
It sounds like
possible.
I know crash when the float that.
Excuse me,
the float lab crash has this setup where
he is developed a screen that has the
lowest amount of light that could be
admitted to the point where you don't
see the edges of the screen,
so you literally,
while you're in the tank,
it's floating above your head.
It's suspended above your head and you
see the image as if it's like just the
video just floating in the sky.
Oh Wow.
And he believes that by separating your
body from a sensory input so you're not
feeling your feet on the ground,
you're not feeling the weight of the
world on your shoulders,
all that jazz.
You're floating.
He thinks you could take in data better.
And so his idea was to show
documentaries and you know,
instructionals and things along those
lines that you would learn quicker that
way.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Right?
Because so much of your brain and the
function of the cerebral cortex is to
integrate the body.
This movement,
Standing Upright,
you know,
and being muscular and moving around.
And if you get rid of that right,
you're kind of opens up and I can take
more in.
Well,
the way I always describe it to people
that haven't used the tank,
I was like,
imagine if you were having a
conversation,
but next to you people were screaming.
If it was an important conversation,
you'd want to get away from those people
screaming because even though you think
of it as a distraction,
it's just input.
It's just data that you have to
consider,
you know,
will you also have to consider your butt
on this chair,
the room,
the dimensions that you're calculating
as you're moving your head around social
cues,
language,
all these different things are all being
calculated and they require resources.
Right?
Well,
when you are in that tank,
there's none of that.
And so your brain feels supercharged.
It feels like you have all these
resources have been opened up to you.
Yeah.
And,
and I agree with you and I think,
you know,
all of those resources,
resources that you're speaking of,
those are sort of the things that to
this idea of what we call the Eco,
you know,
and the same thing with psychedelics,
they formulate the ego and our body and
being separate.
Oh my God,
Joe,
you're strong.
I meant,
you know,
just all these kinds of different things
that create this image of who we think
we are.
Psychedelics,
the tank meditation,
whatever method you want to pick,
gets rid of that and purely gets into
soul land or something else.
Did you ever meet John Lilly?
Oh yeah.
Spent a long time.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Did a lot of what I've done research
with John Research air quotes back in
the day.
That guy,
man,
he's the.
For people who don't know.
We were talking about the guy who
invented the sensory deprivation tank
and he was a pioneer in interspecies
communication with dolphins.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Fascinating guy.
And you know,
the last 20 years of his life,
um,
you know,
the ketamine aspect was such a huge part
of,
of what he was doing and did he get to
and do it the academy and seems to be an
addictive substance.
Um,
look,
I mean,
I love John.
I did.
I thought it was great.
It was a good friend of my dad's and I
certainly wouldn't say anything too
negative about them,
but yeah,
one toke over the line.
That's what Jesus Todd Mccormick has a
very funny story about it.
Do you know what Tom Mccormick is?
I don't know.
Todd's one of the first guys to get
arrested in California for medical
marijuana where he was arrested in the
early or the late nineties,
early two thousands.
And um,
he was one of the first people to find
out that when you are legally growing
marijuana in California,
because of the law,
the medical law,
the federal government can still
prosecute you and when they prosecute
you,
you are in court.
You are not allowed to even bring up the
term medical marijuana because that's
not a real term federally.
So he had,
yeah,
it was a railroad here at railroad and
went to jail.
Um,
but anyway,
point being he was a at John Lilly's.
He actually still owns John Lilly's
tank.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
And he was with John Lilly and John
Lilly,
uh,
invited him to get in the tank.
And uh,
so todd's about to go into the tank and
he says,
do you want to do ketamine?
And he's like,
I'm stepping into the tank.
have,
of course it's John Lilly,
what am I going to say?
Right.
So he hits him with a blast of
intramuscular ketamine and the thigh and
then todd starts freaking out.
He's in the tank and he's freaking out.
So John gets into another tank next to
him,
blasts themself with Ketamine and goes
and visits him.
Glad.
Yeah.
They've found whatever.
Same fucking dimension in the academy in
world.
And it worked.
Yes.
It work.
What does that mean?
I don't know because I've never done
ketamine.
So have you.
Yeah,
I've done it in the tank to w.
okay.
What is,
what happens in there?
Well,
it's been a while since I've done it in
the tank and I'm not so sure I'd do it
again and we're going to do it again.
Uh,
but I'm glad I did it.
Um,
God
man.
Well,
you read that description of what
terence writes about,
ketamine,
that it's,
um,
I'm not sure I'm going to get it exactly
right.
But Ketamine is sort of like you're
going inside of an office building but
it stark and there's nothing in the
office or something like that.
And it's vacant.
Yes.
Um,
well he believed,
turns,
believed that when you were experiencing
like a heavy duty mushroom trip,
you're not just experiencing your trip,
but you're experiencing all the
different people that have ever done
mushrooms together.
Tripping.
That's,
which is why a lot of people when they
take psilocybin and particularly they
get a lot of Aztec and Mayan imagery.
Sorry.
That's the.
Okay.
I grew up on.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
I mean our,
every single indigenous culture,
you know,
except for the eskimos because they
couldn't grow shit.
But every single indigenous culture
until very reasonably,
psychedelics were a core part of their,
of their methodology,
of,
of their tribal rituals.
You know,
anyone's got fucked,
Huh?
Nothing up there,
dude.
You picked a bad spot.
Hit the bad.
Giving so much fish but cut ketamine and
the tank though.
I mean it is.
Um,
it's quite a journey.
I,
it's,
you know,
it's kind of like how the best way I
could explain it is if black,
if you could see colors within
blackness,
if there were shades of black,
if that makes any sense.
Like,
because it's pitch black and the tank
and your head is pitch black,
but somehow you're getting sacred
geometry and sort of kind of visions and
kind of downloads that are in the color
black,
if that makes any sense at all.
Um,
yeah,
I,
God,
I mean,
one of the great moments of my life
actually was picked.
I was getting to Ketamine inside the
tank and uh,
this tank was right outside of my dad's
kind of sliding glass window
which went out into the lawn in his
bedroom up in,
up here in the Hollywood hills.
And um,
you know,
I went in and took a little kedamine Rom
das was visiting that day,
visiting my dad and uh,
the last time they ever saw each other
and he died,
just my dad died just like a month
afterwards.
And I went inside the tank.
Uh,
the two of them were visiting right
outside of the tank hatch.
You know,
how the hatch comes out and they didn't
know I wasn't inside a.
and I was,
I was lost in this whole just completely
fucked.
Just like,
oh my God,
what am I going to do?
And the only thing I knew how to do with
like,
you know,
get the fuck out the hole for people who
don't know what we're talking about is
what people describe the ketamine
experience when you're just kind of
stuck and stuck in life.
It's kind of like code red,
like ejected the eject button,
you know.
So I popped open the hatch and you know,
my dad and Ron doss are sending us close
as you and I right now are right now and
you know,
I'm with self referential enough to know
like,
oh wow,
this is crazy.
Two of them sitting
here right now.
I mean I wasn't stupid and you're naked
and you're tripping and tripping on
academy and everyone is just completely
silent.
Stare at each other.
And Rom Dastis leans into me and goes,
who are you now?
Although,
and it was kind of like a defining
moment in my life journey,
my life,
man.
Are you now fog?
Kind of my mantra
for life now.
But that was over 20 years ago now.
Wow.
So did you feel like,
was that the last time you did it in the
tank?
Uh,
no.
I'm a glutton for punishment.
Yeah,
I did do it one other time after that.
Yeah.
So what is it particularly about the k
hole?
Like when you,
when you go into what they call a k
hole?
Like I've,
I've heard it described by people who
were like recreational users.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't call them psychonauts.
They're more like,
you know,
people go to raves and stuff.
It's dark man and stark and I don't
quite get it.
I don't get the ketamine in the public
rave setting at.
It doesn't make sense to me.
But,
but um,
John loved it.
Lily,
right?
He did loved it.
Ketamine.
Yuck.
But why was that his thing?
Like what did he,
what was his raves about it?
I mean he just.
Oh God.
I mean,
well,
to understand that relationship is also
into understand John a little bit in the
sense that,
you know,
I mean he was the guy who said,
my body is my laboratory.
Right.
You know,
I mean he was,
you know,
one point he gave himself a boob
implant,
you know what I mean?
He was way out there.
And what do you use for the boob
implant?
Don't know,
like the ones that are standard ones
that women get silicone or whatever.
Did he give himself one?
Only one to really.
So he was,
were some darkness involved there and
did he try to make them look like
women's breasts?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If I recall,
you have found a picture of that.
If we could find,
um,
did he lose a bet or is it just like,
no,
I wanted to have breast implants.
I think you'd just,
my body is my laboratory now and sort of
just the.
I mean at that time,
I mean now what does being gender fluid
is such a,
you know,
we could talk about that.
That's really gender fluid.
Know that's one of the things about
breast implants.
It's like at the end of the day everyone
knows what the fuck that is.
There's this,
there's this weird sort of suspension of
disbelief where we're looking at these
water bags that are surgically stuffed
under your skin and we're just
pretending this is like he's your sexual
organs that are plump and ripe on the
vine,
but it's not,
it's,
it's one of the weirdest things about
like being a tripper and deciding to do
that.
It's like,
well,
you're,
you're violating a lot of like bizarre
paradigms.
Yeah,
but I mean he was also kind of bending
the paradigm and kind of bending the
idea of like,
you know,
you can be anything this time around if
I want to be helpful and when it could
be half women,
I can do that.
I'm a doctor in the.
We're living in this golden age of being
able to morph yourself into whatever the
fuck you can imagine kind of thing.
Yeah.
I wonder if numbers early too,
with a lot of those guys that trips so
much,
it's like a,
I think a least for practical purposes.
We would all like to think that you
would like to have a psychedelic
experience and then come back down to
earth and be able to,
you know,
make use of that in the real world.
Like it can kind of benefit you in the
real world.
That's the idea,
right?
That's sort of the idea.
I mean,
so why should we impart those standards
on anybody?
I mean,
you could do whatever you want,
but I think some guys like lily is
probably a prime example that people use
as a point of reference went so far
because it's like where's the baseline
now?
Like there's no baseline for him
anymore.
He was just so out there.
He was,
he was.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah,
I mean I,
I agree with you and also,
I mean not to,
you know,
use you as a,
it's a great model,
but you're a great poster child for
Psychedelic stuff as my dad was,
you know,
it's,
you're well into your adult life and it
changed your consciousness and you're
able to apply it to your work to what
you do and you know,
and it's become very fluid and very
integrated.
You don't hide it.
You're,
you're public about it.
You can,
you found a way to integrate it.
I mean that's the idea of spiritual
practices and it,
it's about integration and I think it's
important to not hide it.
And I think if there's much more fear of
repercussions than actual repercussions,
you know,
I think Terence Mckenna had a great
saying.
He said,
too many people are doing the man's work
for the man race.
Like they don't really care if you're
out doing mushrooms.
That's not what they're trying to do is
they're trying to stop large scale sales
and distribution of schedule one drugs.
They're not trying to stop some dude
from doing mushrooms.
Right.
And look what we're seeing with
microdosing right now,
valley,
I mean more and more people are kind of
coming out of the closet and you know,
supposedly what the names that are kind
of attached to the rumor mill of who's
doing micro dosing in Silicon Valley.
It's huge.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's really,
that's really insane.
It's great.
It is.
And I think as marijuana is now legal in
the state and it becomes legal in more
and more states and hopefully one day
it'll be released from the schedule one,
which is just so crazy that the dea
decided to.
They mean they got to the door this past
summer.
They did and then they decided to pull
away and just keep it at schedule one,
which means there's no medical benefit,
which is a lie.
Well it.
And that's especially fucked and I'm
kind of down on Obama for that as much
as i.
parts of Obama I really do admire.
But that I think was an epic failure.
And considering,
you know,
he just parked in 158 guys.
Most of them are nonviolent drug
offenders and the two are synonymous,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
you treated the symptom man,
that's great.
I'm glad you really those guys from
prison and good for you,
but treat the fucking disease man.
It's like you got to treat.
And now where as we're stepping into
this dark age,
I mean I'm calling it a dark age.
I mean that's the trump dark age of dark
age.
You know,
it's not good for,
for,
for these things.
Well,
I don't know if it is or it isn't,
but what the problem is that when you
know something like,
like if you and I know what's dangerous
and what's not,
like math is dangerous.
Dangerous marijuana is on dangerous.
So when,
when you look at all the facts and then
you look at all the absolutely proven
medical benefits and then you see that
they're denying the existence of these
yet go,
okay,
well the people that are in control of
locking people up and throw them in the
jail,
they're a bunch of liars because they're
just ignoring the science.
There had an the research and the
research that's gone back to the 19
seventies at the Nixon administration
paid for and then ignored and now I
think the bar was even raised,
right.
CBD is just cutting thrown into that
really recently,
which is just a really sneaky thing
because cbd,
much like hemp has zero psychoactive
properties.
It's not doing anything to alter your
consciousness in terms of getting you
high and dry,
but it does amazing stuff for reducing
inflammation for people that have
arthritis.
It's a like a lifesaver.
So,
you know,
the only thing I could kind of in this
thread is kind of think about and talk
about is,
okay,
well what is,
you know,
what's the reason behind this?
I mean if you kind of isolate big Pharma
and talk about that and then,
you know,
I know the CBD industry,
they're big farmers.
The enemy,
right?
Yeah.
But I also have to just kind of say that
big Pharma's main goal is to make money,
you know,
to create products that make money.
It doesn't matter what the product is,
if they told you that you know a plastic
is going to alleviate cancer,
you know,
they would make a plastic pill,
but so what is,
who is the enemy within this that is
making things like cbd and marrow like
is this just kind of left over from kind
of baby boom,
paranoia,
kind of narrow consciousness that we
can't possibly allow these substances
to,
to fix us,
to help us.
I mean,
what is that?
Because there's tremendous profit
potential so something isn't in
alignment to where the depths that can't
be controlled like Viagra,
like it's hard.
It's hard to make Viagra.
Like if you and I wanted to go into the
Viagra business,
who would have to find out what the key
ingredients are,
we'd have to set up a plant and
manufacturing.
I wanted to go into CBD business.
We just have to grow some weed.
Like it's not hard at all.
Okay.
So there's a big difference between
extracting cbd or especially medical
marijuana,
like giving talks.
If you talk about just thc,
right?
You know,
like cooking it down to a candy form or
a pill form.
It's not hard at all.
Right.
But I would like Glaxo Smith Kline,
you can,
you know,
put a billion dollars into making the
best cbd pill and putting it on the
story of every writing the shelf of a
rewrite it and kind of get the
propaganda out there about,
you know,
what it can do,
propaganda being a good thing,
getting the marketing out there,
but all of its benefits.
So what is stopping that?
They just can't copyright it.
They can't,
not patentable,
not patentable or it's nature.
It's,
it would be like trying to patent
oranges.
Like you really,
you can't do it.
It's not going to work.
People are all going to be able to grow
oranges.
Right.
And when it comes to cbd oil,
anyone in this room can grow some
marijuana and extract the CBD from.
It's not an incredibly difficult.
It doesn't require massive resources
like it would if you were gonna make
certain types of Alzheimer's medication
that would be.
Or Parkinson's medication.
I could say it would be competing with
the CBD oil.
Those are very difficult to get and if
you can lock down the doctors and make
sure that they only prescribe these
pharmaceutical drugs that you guys can
profit from and you're the only ones
that can make it,
then you've got that business locked.
There have been people that have done
calculations about all of the different
pharmaceutical drugs that would be
useless or would be unnecessary,
should say if marijuana was legal and
it's pretty staggering.
It's a long list.
It's a huge list and the amount of
profit that the people who make those
pharmaceutical drugs would lose if
marijuana became legal and people just
started realizing like,
hey,
you know,
there's.
And then the other benefits,
like there's no drugs that are like
pharmaceutical drugs that also open you
up,
make you a nicer person,
make you more friendly and commune and
make me more contemplate of,
of your existence a sort of give you a
different perspective that's almost
unattainable.
Without those pharmaceutical.
This isn't really right.
It's not that they don't have those
additional benefits that the pot does.
That's true.
They don't,
which is oftentimes why it's referred to
as a war on consciousness.
Well,
it's got gotta be.
I mean,
that's absolutely what it is because
it's not about drugs because there's so
many drugs that are illegal.
I mean,
come on,
we cannot say there is a war on drugs
when we can go buy a bottle of whiskey
and get a prescription for oxycontin.
It's insane.
In every restaurant you could buy booze
pretty much every restaurant.
And,
and I mean look what the Oxycontin
epidemic has done to America.
I mean,
it's decimated.
It's created a whole generation of
addicts sudden,
you know,
and it's,
it's a dangerous drugs.
So it's a,
it's gotten so warren consciousness.
Yeah.
It's.
And it's really a war for profit,
for controlling the ability to profit
off of people altering their
consciousness because people been,
like you said,
other than people that live in frozen
places where nothing grows.
They've been trying to alter their
consciousness forever.
Okay.
But do you believe,
you know,
I don't know what you're a conspiracy
level kind of meter is,
but do you believe that,
like with all of this said,
that there is still kind of a secret
kind of conspiracy,
government sanctioned funnel that allows
the illegal drug market to still
flourish in some way in order to keep
certain,
you know,
um,
law enforcement endorsement in order,
you know,
maybe skimming off the top off of piles
of cocaine that are coming from Bolivia,
whatever the case may be.
I mean,
I don't know what a case study is,
but you know,
I mean there's still so many coming in
and it's certainly something to be
considered when you.
Are you aware that CIA drug plane that
crashed the jet that had visited
Guantanamo Bay a couple of times and it
crashed in Mexico with tons of cocaine
on him?
Never seen that.
Jamie.
See if he could pull that up.
CIA plane crashes in Mexico with tons of
cocaine.
They overloaded their plane and they had
so much cocaine in it that they,
uh,
they had to a refuel and they tried to
land in Mexico and Mexico is like,
fuck you.
Here it is.
CIA.
Jet Crashes with four tons of cocaine on
board.
I mean,
this is just last month,
a couple months ago.
September 16th.
Oh,
I missed that one.
Well,
this is a recent one,
but it's happened a gang of times.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here it is.
Eight years ago,
saying eight years ago.
Okay.
It crashed in the middle of the jungle.
And Mexico's Yucatan Kang for tons of
cocaine.
The event in the aftermath changed
forever and official narrative of the
war on drugs has for years been pushing
the notion that there is no significant
American involvement in the global drug
trade and no American drug lords.
Right.
Well,
you know the,
you know the barry seal story only a
little bit.
Very seals who used to fly drugs into
MENA,
Arkansas from South America.
You'd go down to South America,
fly drugs and there's photos with him,
with all the CIA guys,
and he'd be partying with Noriega down
in Panama,
Panama,
and this guy was just bringing coke into
United States.
And then when he was scheduled testify,
they assassinated him in his car on the
way the court,
he had had George Bush number in his
phone,
in his pocket.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
As he was executed.
So the whole thing is like,
well,
stories over folks go to sleep,
you know.
Um,
Carson,
I'm the Rick Ross documentary.
Yeah,
I've had on the podcast.
What a story.
Amazing story,
man.
I mean that guy can only drug kingpin in
La Selling Drugs essentially to fund the
war with the contras and the
Sandinistas.
Right.
And they're funneling the product.
Yeah.
Amazing.
He was making millions of dollars for
the US government selling coke.
And you know,
Michael Rupert,
who was a good friend of mine to who
killed himself a few years ago,
who had also been on the podcast couple
times.
Michael was the guy that exposed that.
He was a Los Angeles,
a detective.
Oh Wow.
And he was a,
it was a very famous moment where
Michael Rupert is addressing the court
and he,
he stands up in the middle of this,
all this stuff and,
and says,
and exposes this whole deal.
He's like,
I have personally witnessed the CIA
selling drugs in,
in,
in central Los Angeles,
in south central Los Angeles.
I haven't seen that.
No.
See if you could find that Jamie's,
it's a fucking crazy video.
Or Watch Michael Rupert a exposes
selling drugs in court.
So why did he kill himself?
He was depressed.
He had,
you know,
had some pretty significant depression
long time,
uh,
you being on the police force and all of
the stuff that he had to deal with and
trying to expose corruption.
But listen to this [inaudible] go
fullscreen and crank up the volume
because a former Los Angeles police,
narcotics detective that the agency has
dealt drugs throughout this country.
This is,
uh,
allegations of CIA involvement in drug
traffic.
This is on cspan and this is something
completely unexpected.
So when he stood up in front of these
people and said that to the CEO,
pull that up against.
I can see the top of it.
CIA
Director John Deutch.
That is an answer for a lot of you.
And now had your place.
I refer now.
Kenya place.
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
Why managed care it?
If you don't like what's going on here,
please leave now.
Leave now.
But there are others who do want to hear
what's going on in this room.
Please take your time.
Is there another role?
Specific Agency operations known as a
Pegasus and watchtower.
I have watchtower documents heavily
redacted by the agency.
I was personally exposed to CIA
operations and recruited by CIA
personnel who attempted to recruit me in
the late seventies to become involved in
protecting agency drunk operations in
this country.
I have been trying to get this out for
18 years and I have the evidence.
My question,
if he was very specific,
sir.
If in the course of the igs
investigations and Fred hits his work,
you'll come across evidence of severely
criminal activity.
It's classified.
Well,
you use that classification to hide the
criminal activity or will you tell the
American people the truth?
Yeah,
he went through a lot with
and with many other things and just
decided at one point in time he's
suffering too much and took his own man.
That's,
it's really intense.
And,
and you know,
I,
I try not to be a snake.
I mean I'm pretty open minded,
you know,
and hopeful guy.
But with what we're kind of moving in
towards with the next administration,
I just mean you know about the what's
going on in the Philippines with that
drug.
Yeah.
The crazy drug policy and what trump
called him,
you know,
when he was president elect.
Yeah.
They see that they spoke and he took,
congratulate them for winning,
for killing people.
And I guess trump said on the call that
he was,
congratulations on this drug policy.
It seems to be working.
Oh my God.
They just assassinating people either
just killing people.
He's.
He's talked pretty openly about how he's
just assassinated.
Just drug addicts and users just killing
drug addicts.
That is the.
That's something that happens when you
have so many people in one area.
I mean the Philippines is thousands of
islands for people who don't know and
they're jammed up with people and I
think when you have a lot of crime and
you have a lot of people,
you tend to value those people less and
it just becomes.
Especially when you're a dictator,
I mean essentially that guy's a
dictator.
Yes.
I mean,
whether he's elected or not,
he said what he's doing is Barbera
fucking assassinating people have value
people less just based on kind of
economic on class,
kind of a class struggle,
class struggle,
and also just the sheer volume of them
they're done.
They're not as valuable if there's,
it's like Norway or smaller population
of people.
I think it's just value the people more.
I don't know why.
Use Norway's an example.
Yeah.
But no,
it's a good.
I mean,
all the Scandinavian countries are good.
Um,
did you see the house we live in?
What does that,
the documentary of war and drugs
documentary?
No,
I didn't say that.
Yeah,
it did.
It did.
Was that about five years ago?
Yeah,
about four or five years ago in so many
of those things.
I can't remember them all anymore.
So many of them now.
Um,
it's a really good one.
And uh,
basically like it comes up the,
the,
the final hypothesis is that the war on
drugs,
it's a class war,
you know,
originally we thought it was a race war
and it's still partially true,
you know that.
And what's the guy,
um,
who,
uh,
the first drugs are from the forties and
fifties,
I'm forgetting his name,
Adelson or whatever,
but who,
um,
you know,
it was,
he turned marijuana hysteria in a
Mexican hysteria that they were bringing
it in and this was in the thirties and
forties and created reefer madness than
heroin was kind of pushed into the
ghetto.
And Rick Ross.
Harry anslinger.
Yes.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I then crack brought into the ghetto and
stuff.
But meth sort of becomes the exception
because math is primarily a white
trailer park,
sort of trashy kind of thing and know
how racist I know how racist that was
politically incorrect.
But,
but it's true though.
It's true.
And,
and,
and so we kind of,
we do have a class struggle even then
that's a class issue as well and it just
happens to be Caucasian,
but exactly poor people who really get
into the math,
poor people disenfranchise,
disenfranchised,
unspoken,
unheard of.
No,
I think there's definitely you could say
that,
that the war on drugs as a class war,
it's all.
But it's also like where can they
extract the money?
Where can they get the money?
Well,
the dea has to,
they have to keep people employed,
you know,
and the way to keep people employed is
justify their job.
The way that justify their job is to
continue making arrests and show that
you need to make arrests and show you
have to have laws in place,
which is why you know,
that prison guards will,
will,
will lobby to make sure that marijuana
stays illegal and other drugs are
strictly enforced.
That the policies are strictly enforced
just so they can continue keeping their
jobs right.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But when we still,
like Obama,
during the Obama administration,
he did the,
he took the crack cocaine versus powder
cocaine.
You know,
the discrepancies from 1:20 to one and
he got it down to whatever it is,
eight to one or something so ridiculous.
Still Insane.
Still saying it's the same drug.
It's the same drought,
but it's,
it's purely based on class and race,
you know?
Yeah.
And,
and that is just,
I mean that,
I mean clearly now,
you know,
as we've seen it and as the rhetoric
that's been going on in the last year
during the election cycle,
it's a much bigger problem than we
thought it was.
I mean,
I always knew,
we always knew that this was a problem
race and class and stuff,
but now straight,
you know,
the table,
all the chips on black and you know,
everybody's,
you know,
one of the things that I feel it's
troubling about this election is that a
lot of racists,
like my friend Alonzo boat and had a
great quote,
he said not all trump supporters are
racist,
but all racists are trump supporters.
And that's right.
That's the,
like the bill Maher credit by
Republicans.
What do you say?
I'm not all Republicans are racist,
but all racists are Republicans.
Oh,
that's not true though.
There were a lot of racist Democrats.
That's a bad quote,
but in a terrible quote,
I don't mean.
I mean maybe there was racist that voted
for hilary shore.
Yeah,
I know,
but it's true about,
it's more fun than it is real,
you know,
as a quote,
but it's just,
it seems like they're out in the public
now.
They're out in the open.
I mean,
I've seen so many videos of people that
are trump supporters that are using the
fact that trump's in office now to like
to say a bunch of real really disgusting
racist shit to go crazy and they kind of
got a hall pass,
you know?
That's what,
that's a good way of putting it.
Yeah,
I mean it was like,
obviously,
you know,
I know people as you do who voted for
trump,
sadly I do,
but whatever,
you know,
and not all trump supporters are
uneducated,
racist,
sort of whatever.
Yes.
I'm going to,
broadly,
for the economics,
some people did it for the economic
thing,
but the fact that they gave those other
people a hall pass to act like that and
just,
uh,
just wait,
you know,
really troubling.
Well,
it is,
it's going to be interesting to see this
jeff sessions guy,
what he decides to do because the
attorney general elect that guy that's
coming in,
is that what you say about um,
Attorney General Electric,
a president elect Clinton calling that.
So he's a,
he's a staunch marijuana hater.
He's a,
he's a fucking dyed in the wool
marijuana's for bad people.
Kind of guy.
Just got to get that guy.
Hi.
That's all I have to do.
I mean,
I know he's probably 80.
Yeah,
it's not too late.
I'm going to get them to skim a little
hit.
Don't fuck them up.
Just give him a little and it's just a
little just I,
I'm with you.
And
come on dude,
you'll be fine.
Relax.
Let's go sit in the grass up.
This guy just looked different clouds.
You ever look at them that way?
And it's a thin layer of gas.
It separates us from infinity.
What's your favorite music?
Do you like pink floyd?
Pink Floyd up on these headphones on.
Do you like the Beatles?
I'm sure you like the Beatles,
right?
Everyone does.
He might not.
It might be one of those weird John
Ashcroft guys.
It's really into Gospel music.
Oh yeah.
You remember that John Ashcroft Song,
but what it led to,
God,
look,
she's never sword before.
I think he was one of the scariest guys
that ever obtained any sort of office or
had any sort of power through Ashcroft.
You remember what state was?
You're from Missouri maybe.
I think it was from Missouri.
I don't know.
He lost the election for the
governorship to a dead man.
Did he?
Yes.
That's how much people didn't like that
to a dead guy.
Beat him.
And then Bush.
Do you remember when he did he put
coverings over the naked statues,
covered up the boobs and the in the
Rotunda.
So disturbed by their nakedness.
We survived that.
Barely.
I mean we went to a war that's still
going on because of that asshole and the
other assholes who are in that
administration.
I mean,
that administration was a dark,
dark moment of despair and he's a
alleged weapons of mass destruction that
never existed.
You know,
all of it.
And now trump has talking to carl rove
again,
but not to Dick Cheney.
He's talking about Dick Cheney's fucking
putting on his darth vader mask again.
Dot.
Yeah.
We should use this moment to say rest in
peace.
Carrie Fisher as a just fuck man.
Sixty.
She was only 60.
Oh No.
Did she have a drug problem?
Did she have an alcohol problem?
I'm not current,
but she used to was.
It was a pill thing.
Pills and coke and.
But yeah,
she was,
she was sober in Aa as I understand the
problem is the damage,
those goddamned thing that they due to
your cardiovascular system.
Oh my God.
Just so devastating.
She lived hard.
She lived hard and I think suffered a
lot of physical problems as a result.
And
that was even sadder,
but you've got to think that he probably
went out and the wave of Dick's,
just a tsunami of them probably just
exhausted from origins.
Uh,
somehow I just feel like he squeezed in
a lot of life in 53 years I think.
I think you did too.
I mean,
Pun intended or unintended back George.
Yeah.
But with guys like that,
I,
I often wonder,
you know,
with being a songwriter or I hit maker,
is it,
is it better to have had,
you know,
one hit or a few hits and then
completely fade away?
Not that he faded away into obscurity,
maybe he's not a good example or to not
have it at all because I think George
did kind of carry with him that like he
was no longer current sort of thing.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing where someone's not
famous anymore.
They're kind of a joke.
Whereas a regular person,
not a joke.
Like,
here's an example.
Do you remember when Gary Coleman was a
security guard?
He had a,
he had to get a job and it was a real
problem because Gary Coleman was just
trying to do his job and just trying to
get paid so he can eat,
you know,
it was just trying to feed himself like
all the rest of us.
And people would come up to him and take
pictures of them and mock him and they
would use him as a joke.
But you don't use a regular security
guard as a joke.
Like if you see a regular security
guard,
you're like,
what's up man?
How you doing?
Yeah.
I'm going to go this building right
here.
Who See your id?
Cool.
Everything's fine.
You don't say,
ah,
you're a fucking security guard.
Look at Joe.
Because he used to be something greater,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a poor Gary Coleman.
He was a security guard.
Yeah.
That's so troubling.
And it kind of really plays into the
whole idea of fame and perversion and
America and the things that we hold
dear.
The things that are valuable to us,
kind of the American,
that disillusion of American values,
which I think that's the rise of trump.
To me,
it's a values thing.
I had a guy gave me a hard time once
about not about fear factor being
canceled and he was a.
I'm a fucking a here at cvs.
He was working at cvs.
He's like,
what happened to his show?
And I said it was canceled no more.
Show her like,
like all attitude.
I'm like,
dude,
shows go away.
Yeah.
They go on and then they get canceled.
We had was,
we had a good run me,
but he was like,
he was being aggressive about it.
It was so weird.
It was like,
what?
Just bizarre detachment from reality.
You're working at fucking cvs dude.
Like I'm not giving you a hard time
about being a cvs guy.
Right?
But if,
if I was the guy from fear factor and
then I was a cvs guy,
how bad would you shit on me.
Then I'm just coming in as a guy buying
some cough drops.
That's right.
Like what a weird thing that we have
this,
this need to.
When someone attains a very high status
and then falls off of that,
what we think we think they're down.
We want to attack.
It's like a,
an animal thing.
But in your case,
best thing that ever happened to you?
Yeah.
I mean I don't think he knew.
You know,
he probably didn't know that it had a
standup career that I was doing the UFC
or anything.
He was just like,
oh,
you're a fucking loser.
No,
what is your show?
I was like crazy accent.
All aggressive.
Like,
all right dude.
Like that is.
It was like.
But it was so blatant.
It was confusing.
It was like I being pumped.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the idea of like a,
uh,
you know,
winning that idea,
you've got to win,
man.
That trumps trump thing.
That's the trump thing that's really
disturbing is that that winning thing
got a win,
got to win.
And not this lack of person.
I mean,
he's fucking 70 man.
That ain't a lot of time left bro.
I,
if you're super lucky,
you got 20 summers left.
If you're super lucky,
if everything goes great and he's not
that healthy,
he's fat is fat.
His Chin just has like a very slow
sloping lab of skin that's loosely
attached to his neck.
That goes down to his collarbone and he
doesn't look like a healthy 70 year old.
And I don't think so either.
Sylvester stallone is older than him.
That's a good piece of A.
Yeah,
there you go.
Put it in perspective.
Sean connery total of both of them.
Yeah,
they're both older than that.
That whole idea.
It's just that destruction of sort of
like the things that we have instilled
as being an important.
Like you could have a winning
temperament.
I'm going to make America win again.
Why is that the most important sort of
attribute for someone to attain to what
does that even mean when and it's so
attached to like a financial thing,
right?
Like what kind of value system is that?
Like there are other ways to quote
unquote win at,
into time.
It'd be tied to money,
but the problem is it becomes
attractive.
You know,
when you see someone who has a slick
back hair and a private jet and he takes
a photo with his expensive shoes on his
private jet and it's on his instagram
and then he's,
you know,
that all stuff becomes very attractive
and then people aspire to that and then,
you know,
you get that Gordon Gekko greed is good
thing you write,
greed is good,
but also like that level of aspiration.
First of all,
it's pretty much not attainable.
I mean mullins.
Attainable.
Yeah.
Put One or what to private jet rich.
I mean that is.
Some people can do it.
They obviously have one percent of the,
one percent of percent.
I mean that level,
you know,
like the people were following the,
those people on instagram and instagram
who have instagram.
Okay,
Grandpa fucking the on that series of
tubes.
It's a series of tubes.
God dammit.
Right?
The facebook.
Um,
but I mean if you're trying to climb the
mountain,
you want to climb everest.
If you want to be the Gordon Gekko Guy,
you want a private jet and the slicked
back hair and the put it never ends.
It doesn't ever indifference.
Well,
that's weird when you see the really,
really,
really rich guys who are still smashing
and just every day trying to attain new
and we always assume they achieved
enlightenment was like this idea that
like,
well he's got $50,
billion dollars.
Why doesn't he just retired?
He never fucking retire to read Steve
Jobs.
Last words.
Have you ever read that?
No.
Let me say you might want to bring them
up,
Jamie.
It's really,
really fucking cool.
It's like he's,
it's his last,
whatever mean,
maybe not the last word he said to his
wife or something,
but it's kind of his last cohesive
thought was like,
look,
I'm,
you know,
many people,
the world views me as completely
successful and,
and I've achieved so much in business,
but you know,
my personal life and everything that he
was lacking,
you know,
so he was just Kinda sorta coming clean
about the imbalance and it all kind of
coming clean about the,
you know,
the levels of discontent in the path of
the heart,
the soul,
the path of the spirit.
Because he was essentially a spiritual
guy and you know,
with a meditator is practitioner of Zen
and into Neem Karoli Baba and all sorts
of things.
But he got so wrapped up in those
vicious sort of cycle of having to
produce product,
product,
product and you know,
apple essentially in,
in his words,
you know,
he made it into a product company and
that's how we defined it.
And not even an idea company was a
product company.
And then products are based on having to
have the latest version of the product
over and over and over again,
and he just got wrapped up in kind of
lost his soul isn't an interesting in
that like bill,
Bill Gates and Steve Jobs were like the
two competitors that we always thought
of.
Bill Gates was thought to be the
business guy who's the cold hard and he
was a lot of ways.
Sure back in the day,
but if you look at him in his older
years,
he became very charitable,
involved in a bunch of humanitarian
efforts and does a lot of amazing work
and is using his substantial wealth for
a lot of good and doesn't work anymore.
It's just he's done with all that.
He's all just doing humanitarian work
and helping people,
which is kind of beautiful.
And he became,
you know,
this different guy.
As he got older he became wiser and
became much more involved in doing good
and trying to help and trying to use
that immense amount of money that he
acquired by being a ruthless sort of
business gangster,
but doing it for good.
Which is kind of really fascinating.
Then he decided,
hey,
I'm going to step back here.
I'm going to set,
set back and think about what I'm doing
and what's really important.
I mean,
this last stage of life.
And that's a,
you know,
that's Karma Yoga.
Karma Yoga is,
you know,
about the um,
uh,
you know,
what to the path of the Saudi in,
in India,
like traditionally the path of the saw,
do you know,
kind of historically.
And traditionally it's some,
you know,
the who grows up as born in India and is
raised into education event,
become a householder,
householder,
meaning getting married and has kids.
I'm works as career provides for the
kids.
And then in the last third of his life
becomes a Saudi drops.
All of it walks away.
Kids are grown up,
out of the house,
kind of leaves of his wife,
which is kind of a bummer for her,
but for her.
But in kind of a concept,
maybe she was annoying.
Maybe she wanted to keep wanting to
leave anywhere verses and shit.
And he's like,
no,
we have to meditate.
No,
I'm shopping online,
but they need to take off and it becomes
a wandering then to India and that's the
path of this.
I'll do.
It's kind of broken into different
phases.
I don't know if that's the right way to
do it either.
Oh,
I don't know,
but it's fascinating.
It's an interesting.
It's an interesting way of,
of,
of looking at it that,
okay,
you have achieved a lot.
You've accumulated a lot and now I can
go be of service.
Well,
service is always a great idea.
Um,
wasn't the Saudis are really into Hash,
right?
Isn't that the big thing?
I'll make chillums you can smell it.
Depends what a,
what a lineage you belong to.
I've sat with some of them in the Naga
Baba is and the Colombo Mineola and part
of sat with them.
It is amazing how when people discussed
religion,
if they discuss hinduism or the Sikhs or
any,
any of the various strains of,
of religions that are inexorably
connected to psychedelics,
psychedelics are rarely discussed.
You know,
I mean if you go and you read like the
vimanas or read any of the ancient Hindu
text,
there's so many references to soma and
so many references to what is obviously
some sort of a psychoactive substance,
you know this.
But when people talk about like Hinduism
and hardly ever comes up,
can you talk about Yogis and dues,
it hardly ever comes up in the modern
sort of take on it because there have
been a,
there's kind of a revival of within
Hinduism have kind of an Orthodox
version of it,
which is,
you know,
and free and that's sort of,
that's kind of a modern revival within
the Hindu tradition,
you know,
so they've kind of pushed that aside.
But yeah,
I mean,
you know,
a bong is the,
it's the,
it's like a powdery pot thing that you
just kind of,
you know,
you swallow some of it.
Yeah.
How does that,
what does that stuff made with its,
um,
you take like the leaves and you grind
up the leaves into a fine powder.
Then there's some kind of cooking
process and then,
but within just the leaves,
the shake,
all the scraps is enough and you can
extract the thc in some kind of cooking
process and you make it into a fine
powder and just throw it down,
throw it down,
and it hadn't.
It gets you pretty,
pretty toasty.
Yeah.
Well I know that there are also into the
crystals and they take the crystals and
mash them up and sort of make like kind
of a hash out of,
uh,
the,
the scrape from the thc crystals.
What is that called?
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
We both know some sort of a mushy sort
of waxy type jazz.
They'd take that.
Yeah.
But I mean,
again,
back to the original thread of our
conversation,
it's like every tradition has some kind
of Sacrum,
a mind altering sacrament,
vedic texts,
all these different.
Uh,
I mean they look,
I mean they had to be,
they,
they obviously were aware of these
substances and they found these
substances.
There was no science back then.
There was no real understanding of
what's going on in the world.
No real understanding of your body,
but there was these,
this access to this stuff.
Hey man,
you see those things that are grown on
that couch it if you take that,
you will meet God.
Right?
And then people did it and did meet God
and they're like,
Holy Shit.
You're telling the truth.
Like there is like everybody wants.
Like if you think about religions,
if you think about the stories that
people tell of the wise men and were,
you know,
the experience,
the burning Bush and God gives them the
10 commandments and all these different
things that happen.
There are all sorts of beautiful
stories,
but your everyday life experiences so
flat and fucking boring.
And then you do take these things and
go,
well,
this is just gonna be just like
everything else,
just flat and boring and bullshit.
And he take,
take those mushrooms that you pluck off
that cow shit and all of a sudden,
oh,
it's
exposed to you in some grand way.
And then your whole life becomes about
worshiping that.
I mean,
that's.
Mckenna always argued that,
um,
the,
all the ancient cattle worshiping,
um,
religions and cattle worshiping
civilizations like to talk to all he
took and all these really old,
old cultures that that's what was all
about,
that these people had found out that
cows grow mushrooms on their shit and
that they,
they weren't able to differentiate
between the,
they thought it was coming out of the
cow's body,
the cow would shit it out and they
didn't understand sports.
So they thought it was inside the cow
and it would grow in the shed.
And that was your portal to God.
Wow.
Be rarely hear that discussed.
I mean you always hear it discussed in
terms of like an agricultural and
resource that that's why they worship
the cows,
you know,
that not just makes me think it goes
back to that,
you know,
and I'm someone who I'm a very spiritual
person and have a practice and all that
kind of stuff.
But like that just brings up the
question to me,
it's like,
did we invent God as a result of those
experiences?
Kind of like a good.
Chris Ryan,
if he was here,
you know,
kind of like the hunter gatherer kind of
tribal,
you know,
when we were just starting starting to
learn to depict our experiences and talk
about our experiences and creating like
an oral history and sort of like the
first kind of existential dilemmas and
which many say came from psychedelic
awareness back in those days.
So is that what led to the creation of
God and you know,
and to me it doesn't make a difference.
Being a believer of God.
I don't really care if it's real or myth
or not.
It works for me,
but it does make.
It almost doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if it benefits you to
believe in it,
it benefits you.
People ask me that all the time,
like,
oh my God,
you actually believe in flying monkeys
and a blue guy playing a flute and in
the fields I've seen flying monkeys.
Shit.
Those people talking shit.
I've seen jokers giving me the finger.
They're spinning and geometric patterns
that were infinite.
I've seen a lot of shit that's way more
ridiculous than a guy with a harp and
not only have you seen it and have I
seen it,
but I can tell everybody listening how
to see it.
Yeah,
they can see.
You can see it.
If you have the courage and the
substances,
you can see it.
Yes,
you can and it works on everybody.
Except I think it's the DMT apparently
doesn't work on everybody because like
one out of a thousand or it like
literally doesn't do shit.
Jamie.
Jamie doesn't get high off of edibles.
This fucking freak over here.
He give Jamie like a super powerful
edible.
Barely does a goddamn thing to him.
Yeah.
It took like 1200 milligrams before a
concert and drove home two hours later.
The edibles today in my.
He's afraid to Goddamn Halligan working
the controls over there.
I mean for the first time in my life I
feel like kind of finally like an old
hippie.
Like,
oh my God,
the edibles when I was a kid.
It's not like that today,
man.
That shit's insane.
These fucking things.
This is a jumbo spray.
I took 10 hits of this before maybe 12,
I forget,
for a Sam Harris' podcast I was.
I was like,
I was skiing downhill straight with.
I wasn't crashing,
but I was figuring out how to barely
stay up the entire conversation.
I'm like,
what in the fuck have I done?
I was so high.
It was probably as high as I've ever
been in my life.
Was at the last seminar,
spoke to Sam.
Sam's a perfect guy to be that baked
with because all you have to do is just
wind them up and say something and he's
so eloquent that he could just continue
to go on these amazing as long as you
keep up with what he's saying.
So you have like good questions.
He is,
but I.
and it's all due respect to stem and I
do think you're smarter than me in terms
of Iq,
but I do think he uses head intelligence
to kind of Kinda shuck and jive you a
little bit.
Shuck and jive household.
Well,
I'm not like.
I mean,
he's so smart and so articulate and
bright,
obviously brilliant and mad respect for
him,
but I just don't think he's right about
what.
Well,
let's take Islam for example.
I mean there's so many things,
but I mean,
um,
uh,
Islam and it's sort of like the right to
sort of like prepare for violence.
Um,
and kind of self defense.
I don't really agree with that
philosophy.
Um,
and I just,
I don't agree with it because I think if
you,
it just invites the consciousness into
your head to where you are going to have
to use it.
I'm not interested in the idea that self
defense and preparing for something sets
up the stage to make something happen
different than say getting in there in
the octagon and the MMA stuff and you
know,
well that's a competition the
competition.
But you think like maybe like guy walks
around with a gun and a knife and I
think it will improve vest and get
invites the consciousness into,
into,
into the atmosphere and it creates the
energetic cycle of having to use that.
And then Sam kind of throws up those
statistics that well,
it's about the same odds as having a car
crash or as you are going to experience
some kind of act of violence in your
life where you will need to learn how
to,
I dunno,
do something self defend yourself and I
just,
I don't.
Maybe you can throw at that math to me
and I think it depends on certain
socioeconomic conditions,
but I just don't think that's true.
I just don't want that consciousness in
my life and I don't think we should need
to dissolve that consciousness.
I certainly think you're free to not
have those thoughts in your head and to
choose to take the path of love and
acceptance and just passively and move
through this life.
But the reality of human beings is like,
I've been unfortunately watching some
videos online.
I watched this video today,
have a guy kicking some lady down the
stairs for no reason.
He was behind her and then they're
looking out for.
They're trying to find him in the UK.
They've got photos of him,
but he just,
she was walking in front of them.
Don't go on the stairs and he walked up
behind her and just,
just a random person kicked her down
this flight of stairs and she's horribly
injured.
And uh,
I,
I've seen a bunch of those things do
happen.
You can run into the wrong people.
Yes they do.
They do have you,
um,
steven pinker,
minerals,
Angel Story,
you know,
we are in,
yes,
those things happen and look around the
world today and flip on the news and
it's highly disturbing.
But we are living in the most peaceful
time.
Amazing time of our,
of our existence.
You know,
if you were a 30 year old man in the
year 1500,
you're most,
the highest cause of death was not
disease or infection.
That was an act of violence.
You were going to be raping and
pillaging and you just had to defend
your food supply for Granuloma.
And we have come to some kind of
understanding,
some kind of collective consciousness
that has morphed itself together in the
form of cooperation.
We have to shit.
And there's so many of us know and it's
getting more of us.
The planet is getting smaller.
We have to cooperate,
I agree with you,
but what do you do with those guys that
kick women down flights of stairs like
that?
Um,
you,
I mean,
I guess there's some sort of forum of
um,
you know,
I guess punishment and we do have a,
we live in a society where law and order
is maybe a necessary evil.
And I,
I,
you know,
and I'm sure there's some kind of like
incarceration,
but ultimately,
you know,
you got to love them.
You've got to have compassion for them
and you've got to just teach them with
compassion that their action was wrong.
Don't kick the lady down the stairs,
man,
here's why you shouldn't do that and I
love you and it's going to be okay.
People right now are up in arms.
They want to kick your ass.
That's cool.
It was a right now in Nebraska,
like this fucking happy fucking Tim
leary.
Pussy kick is a kick his ass.
He pass,
but you know,
and I'm a on a different,
you know,
it's a beautiful thought.
It is.
It's gone.
Be there.
Is there some people that you can run
into though?
Unfortunately you're better off.
It's like that expression about having a
gun.
You're better off having it,
not needing it then needing it and not
having it.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't agree.
So I get it.
I get it.
And I understand the arguments about
that guy who was a.
was it in um,
I think it was in Minnesota.
He was running around stabbing people
and then some guy who was a concealed
carry permit holder pulled out his gun
and shot the guy and killed them.
And it was a,
one of those things that people point to
like,
Hey,
this guy was a competition shooter
concealed carry permit and any save
people's lives because this guy was
killing a bunch of people.
But those case studies compared to the
case studies that go wrong,
I don't know what they are.
I don't have the metrics,
but I bet there what 10 to 1:20 to one.
Sure.
It's,
it's way easier to get a gun just to
just to go and get a gun than it is to
become a competitive shooter.
Like what that guy was,
was the rarest of the rare.
Someone is not just competent with a
firearm,
but an expert level.
Here he is man who shot crossroads mall.
Terrorists is us p,
s a competitor.
Three guns shooter.
Yeah.
So this guy is just a bad ass gun
carrier and that's fine.
But that is the rarest except right.
I'm positive of it.
Right.
But it is real,
right?
Sure.
So it can happen.
So he was right.
So his thought was one day if I am
carrying a gun,
I'll be able to save people's lives.
That's,
that's,
that's fine.
And I and protect myself.
Okay.
I get that.
But the hundreds of others that go
along,
then somehow there's so many loopholes
in the system of crazy people who get
guns and go to sandy hook and it's,
it's,
it's slow.
That's a terrible example.
I'm not worth.
And those are illegally acquired gun.
That's a gun that was acquired by a
person who is mentally ill and his
parents didn't protect the guns.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a different story.
But yeah,
you're right.
You know,
I just think that the risk versus reward
is just,
it's just far too unbalanced,
but it's definitely it.
The ability to shoot someone and kill
someone by pulling that little tiny
muscle on your finger is kind of crazy.
I mean it's the amount of power that you
have in doing so.
It is,
that's a glitch in the matrix using
matrix analogy,
but it is,
it's a glitch in the matrix man and it
just,
it plays into kind of every fallacy of
the human condition,
you know,
and it's like why?
How did we let that happen?
How did we make it so easy to take
someone else's life?
So what do you say if I may.
Exactly.
Are you the president of United States?
Does the,
does Zach Larry say no more military
disaster.
He say police officers can't have guns.
We all need love.
Everybody gets their guns taken away.
Like what do you,
how do you deal with everything?
Yeah,
I mean,
and it's not something that you can just
do it.
Yeah.
It's not something you can just do
overnight.
I'm not,
you know,
naive enough or you know,
stoned enough or meditate enough to
think that that we should get high,
maybe we think about in a different way
and there,
and there were already 300 million guns
in America.
I think there's more.
I think there are more guns in America
than there are human beings.
And here's what's crazy.
It's not like we're like,
well,
we're good.
No,
we're fucking making guns like crazy.
Well,
as we're sitting here,
the chunk,
chunk,
machines are turning out gun.
But yes,
exactly who becomes president.
I know it's highly unpopular and people
will get pissed at me,
but we stopped the sale of all.
Unless you have a very specific kind of
UK style hunting exceptions.
Do you eat meat?
I do.
You do?
I didn't for awhile,
but I do again.
Why'd you start again?
Um,
I got sick.
I'm not from not eating meat.
I just,
um,
I got this terrible flu and it was just
really,
really sick and just like,
you know,
not a cold.
I mean it was like a terrible flu and
all I could think about was I want a
Turkey sandwich
cheese.
Huh.
And I was like fuck it.
And I had a Turkey sandwich and I felt
better and I never went back.
Wow.
Eat everything.
Burgers,
everything.
The whole deal.
I kind of do.
Do you eat factory farmed food?
I really,
really,
really try not to.
But you do?
I do.
I mean,
I can't say that I don't,
but I don't.
I mean in the most dire emergency I give
you super hungry,
super hungry.
You know what I do is I'm an,
I have to,
it's kind of a,
a loosely in the airport,
a god Damn airport you got me in the
airport and I'm just like,
whatever.
I always get to the airport way too
early because I just,
I liked being in the airport early.
I like to be in that.
It's like a neutral zone between there
and here and just I love it.
I love hanging around the airport and I
get there.
I'm hungry and I'm just it in like the.
I used to fuck up at the airport all the
time with blueberry muffins,
chocolate croissants.
That was my shit and I'm a sucker for
the egg mcmuffin.
Sadly.
Those are good.
They taste good.
That's not the worst thing in the world
for you,
quite honestly.
No,
it's not for the.
The Ham factory farm.
Yeah.
It's not the worst thing in the world
for,
but Mcdonald's is the devil.
But what am I going to do?
Well,
it's the best I can really do.
Yeah.
It's a weird world.
Well,
a lot of vegans would disagree with
that.
They would say,
well,
you definitely not doing the best you
can if you're out there eating egg.
That's true.
That's not the best you can.
That's fair.
Fair enough.
Oh God.
No.
Meat.
Vegans and I argue a lot.
Do they do?
Yeah.
A lot.
When you are on the social media,
um.
Well,
and,
and it's weird because I'm kind of
philosophically,
I'm on their side.
I'm with philosophically,
but not in practice.
I just add to,
it doesn't feel I'm not quite ready for
that and I have to admit I'm just not,
you know,
I am where I am.
I am,
but what I argued with him about is,
um,
it's,
it's a constant social media argument is
that we are omnivores.
We are,
yeah.
We definitely are omnivores.
We eat what's around us.
Yeah.
We always have.
There's a way to,
you can cruelty free meat,
but there's a way.
There's not a way where you could have
cruelty free mass consumption that the
real problem is cities like,
you know,
unless you have a co op where you guys
are growing your own.
What was the second part?
Sorry,
I didn't,
I didn't understand.
Not you can eat cruelty free,
but you can't put in a mask consumption
like environment,
like 7 million people living in
Manhattan,
like good luck getting cruelty free meat
to all 7 million people cowspiracy
inside that area.
You know,
it's just,
you have to bring it.
I mean,
what we've done
over the last 150 years is moved
completely away from agriculture in,
in these cities and and drive things in
and trucks.
Have you ever seen some of the old
models of what they were?
The way that when they were planning
cities,
like in the early 18 hundreds when they
were designing New York and a couple
other cities,
they had set up areas for agriculture
areas for livestock and they had them in
cities and so they didn't have this
notion that we have now that everything
would be driven in and trucks because
they didn't have trucks,
so when they had.
When they had cities in the 17,
hundreds and later there,
there was no way to get all that food to
millions and millions of people,
so they literally had a gross stuff in
cities,
which is a way better way to do it.
Michael Pollan.
Omnivore's dilemma.
Yeah.
It's great.
He's also getting into psychedelics now,
which is pretty cool,
but just recently he's doing some really
interesting who was a wonderful person
who popped him into the matrix that I
don't know,
but I'm gonna use the matrix.
I'm in touch with them and going to do a
podcast with him.
Oh,
that's great.
Figure it out.
But um,
yeah,
I mean his whole kind of,
you know,
in the Omnivore's dilemma and some of
those other books,
like the biggest problem with our food
supplies that we have lost our
connection to how food got there up
until 100,
100,
maybe 120 at the turn of the century,
the 19th and the 20th century.
Every body had a relationship with their
food.
They knew you went to the produce
person.
It didn't come from a shelf in a box,
you know,
you had,
you knew where it was sourced and it was
kind of.
And if you ate meat,
you kind of,
you saw the bloodiness and you've just
saw like even if you didn't kill it and
slaughtered and butchered you,
you knew,
you know,
it wasn't this prepackaged thing that
just comes from magic,
the bacon very,
you know,
and that that's our problem,
right?
Food comes from the shelf.
Nobody understands.
I think there's a giant disconnect with
and it's,
it's so many people.
The problem is like it used to be that a
few people were disconnected and most
people were connected and now it's
completely turned on its head.
And when you have 20 million people in
Los Angeles and what percentage of the
20 million people in Los Angeles acquire
their own food from either growing
plants or hunting,
they're like,
no one's not.
Almost none.
Zero point one,
one,
whatever it is.
It's kind of crazy when you consider
that it's an essential part of being a
person is consuming food.
But there's,
there's also this beautiful feeling that
you get and the vegans have this feeling
as well.
When you grow your own food and you grow
food in a garden and you pick your salad
and cut up your cucumbers,
like this all came from the ground right
out there,
but there was a really interesting
article that was written by a Vegan that
was essentially saying there are no
vegetarians and that the only way is
like it is actually impossible to be a
vegetarian,
not,
not meaning that it's impossible for you
to live and eat vegetables,
but those vegetables need dead animals
in order to be alive and that animals
are consumed by plants and that is what
fertilizer is all about and whether or
not it's the fertilizer was just the
poop.
No,
no,
no.
There's a lot of it is actual decaying
matter and in order to be healthy in
particular,
like what we're doing,
most of them,
you know about Fritz Hobert.
Do you know what the harbor methodists
don't know in,
during World War One,
there was this,
a German scientist named Fritz harbor,
and he came up with the harbor method of
extracting nitrogen from the air.
Most people think of the air as being
oxygen,
right?
The air is 78 percent,
I think,
nitrogen,
right.
And you can extract that nitrogen from
the air and use it as fertilizer.
And so because of Fritz harbor,
they have been able to extract this
nitrogen and use it to fertilize plants
because before they used like emulsified
fish and the fish was like a big one,
like dead fish and fish bones and things
along those lines because that is when
it decays and breaks down.
That is the food for these plants.
Okay.
So what would a Vegan,
why would the vegans opposed this in the
sense that we're opposing?
They're not?
No,
it's just,
I think it's just what he wrote it.
He's the guy who wrote it was a Vegan,
but essentially we're saying that
there's this massive cycle life and even
pointed to Michael Pollan's work,
um,
because Paula has written about the
emerging science of sentient plant life
and that he believes that what's going
on with plants is very similar to what's
going on with like maybe our
understanding of a lot of different
things.
It's like as our,
uh,
understanding expands,
we have to sorta reclassify what we
think those things are.
Like for the longest time they thought
that fish couldn't feel pain.
Right?
And that was,
oh,
don't worry about fish,
can't feel pain.
And now they're saying,
well,
we appreciate it.
They can.
Yeah,
we were,
we have a different understanding of
what pain is to them.
It might be a different sensation,
but there's very clearly some alarms
that are going off.
It was very clearly some sort of a
reaction that seemed can be pointed out
for plants like plants.
Not only do they have a reaction,
but plants,
when you play the sound of caterpillars,
chewing leaves certain plans,
like the Acacia tree,
um,
has the ability,
when it hears leaves being chewed,
it changes the taste of the leaves that
extract some sort of a chemical and that
chemical does something to the taste of
plants that makes them so an addable
that some animals have starved to death
because upwind there were animals that
were chewing plants that sound came
downwind through either smell or some,
some sort of a communication thing
that's going on with the mycelium and
with the,
the,
the root structure and the plants down
wind had changed their tastes and the
animals wouldn't eat them anymore and
they were starving.
Wow.
That's far out,
man.
That just kinda makes me think like,
what's gonna be the next sort of like
Vegan movement.
Maybe some kind of IOWASCA ceremony in
the middle of like a of a garden or like
an agricultural thing where we're just,
we're listening for and trying to make,
you know,
we have to make peace with that.
Everything needs everything else in
order to make it well.
It's,
I think it's a like a suffering and a
respect thing,
right?
Yeah.
And then then you also have to consider
if plants are sentient life forms,
how fucked up is it to have these
gigantic large scale agricultural setups
where you are,
you are completely unnaturally changing
the landscape in order to grow corn or
in order to grow lettuce or strawberry.
It's like that is not normal.
Like it's not normal to have 7,000 acres
of corn.
Right?
Like in just corn all in a neat row that
you could see from space and it's.
And it's destroying the soil to.
Yeah,
completely.
It's completely destroying the soil.
But like with this idea of like having,
you said respect and in pain,
kind of getting into that idea like do
you think um,
and I'm,
my opinion is results may vary and I'm
not so sure.
But if everybody had the data and saw
the data about factory farming for
instance,
that they would change in us,
act accordingly and not eat that shit
anymore.
Definitely not everybody.
Some people don't give a final.
I think some people's doing fuck and
those Gordon Gekko type dudes,
the slicked back hair that I'm like,
fuck it,
I'm here to win Gimme that burden.
Trump,
trump,
trump.
I mean,
I've thought about myself.
I've seen every one of those movies.
I've read every book,
you know,
I didn't work.
I'll have a muffin from time to time and
I'm like,
what is wrong with me?
Like is there something,
am I associate to do that?
Because it's easy to do.
If somebody said,
Oh,
you're hungry,
why don't you shoot that pig in the head
and a cut off a leg and throw it on the
smoker?
Well then you would have a real issue.
It'd be like,
I don't want to do that.
Okay,
well why don't you pull those beets out
of the ground?
Well,
if you put on these headphones,
you can hear the beat scream or their
parents.
I'm like,
AH,
fuck off.
I mean,
I don't know,
but I don't know.
I don't think anybody knows,
but if there's just something about
plausible deniability that's kind of
hardwired into us in all aspects of her
life.
Not just food,
but war and politics and money and greed
and oil and everything.
That's what it takes to get oil to this
damn country and everything that goes on
to fill up our car.
You know what I mean?
A plausible deniability is definitely
the way to look at it.
The extreme ability to detach ourselves
from the consequences of our actions,
you know,
because it's convenient in the moment.
That's right.
Yeah.
And convenient in the moment to just buy
that quarter pounder with cheese.
Not Think about it that it's a ground
animal burger.
That's right.
Know,
and you know,
it's only going to cost me two bucks.
Yeah.
And you get away from that,
which is kind of crazy.
I mean,
it really is amazing.
If it wasn't connected to such horrific
crimes against nature,
it's amazing.
What's amazing that you can just go.
So I mean,
what an incredible system they've
developed outside of food.
Just what you know,
the economic factors for how convenience
equals pleasure equals like an economic
value that is usually low.
How that has all sort of work together
to kind of create this system that we're
living in now and we have this again,
this plausible deniability kind of
hardwired thing to ignore it.
Know Walmart is a great example.
I mean,
you know,
the sort of this disenfranchised middle
of the country,
you know,
and they did lose their jobs in that
area of the,
of the country's decimated,
but they all shop at Walmart and that's
the,
that's,
that's part of what the heart of what
the problem is.
It's cheap,
it's convenient.
You're still going.
And it's like,
well,
what's it going to be?
You know,
pick a horse that's been interesting is
that this is all really recent,
right?
I mean this is all from the industrial
revolution on this is all this last
couple of hundred years of civilization
where we've sort of entered into this
wage existence.
You know,
where people are living this way and
buying this horrible fucking factory
produced food.
And even more recent that,
I mean,
yes,
it's all can be traced back to the post
industrial revolution stuff,
but even just like the massive high
perkins can consumerism,
that's only really taken off since the
mid nineties.
Yeah.
There's a cool little movie out called
uh,
the minimalists.
I mean,
after awhile it kind of,
uh,
you know,
I got it and I didn't finish the whole
thing.
But the first hour is fascinating.
It's about these guys that wrote a book
called the minimalists and about,
um,
you know,
there were all kinds of corporate ladder
kind of American successful guys and
just consuming,
consuming,
buying shit,
buying Shin,
buying shit.
Then all of a sudden they just kind of
had the kind of big,
kind of cliched awakening.
Like,
oh my God,
maybe I don't need all this shit.
But the data that they present from
what's happened in the mid nineties on
sort of as a result of the internet boom
with instant gratification,
one click shopping and disassociation of
just the accumulation of stuff.
And we live in,
um,
you know,
we live in bigger houses now than we've
ever lived.
Square footage wise,
they've never been so big before and
yet,
um,
you know,
they've put all these heat maps on a,
they did the study where they put heat
maps on these homes to see where people
were living in the homes hanging out and
like the average family and like they're
huge kind of mansion or something.
Only uses like 40 percent of the house.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
And also has a self storage unit to go
with it somewhere else,
you know,
it's just this endless kind of
relationship we have with it.
So I watched hoarders the other night
and there were some digital hardcore
bought two houses next to his house
because he had so much shit like that.
He had to move the shit to other houses.
It was fucking crazy.
Orders
is gnarly.
But this is a weird hoarder because it
was a guy who had some money.
He bought two ounces.
Yeah.
It wasn't like a hoarder,
like some poor person that was going to
yard sales and buying used clothes.
And then putting them in bags and their
house and stack them up the ceiling with
newspapers and stuff.
This was a guy who had all these
collectibles and uh,
he was a neurosurgeon,
which is really,
really interesting.
Interesting.
Yeah.
He lives in Vegas and he wanted to be
known for his collection.
He had crazy stuff like he had,
um,
there within two.
He has a lot of space memorabilia.
Like he had a,
uh,
a scale model of one of the challengers
or one of the space shuttles rather.
He had,
um,
one of the test lunar modules that a
buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong
apparently had used in testing and in
preparation for the Apollo missions and
hit a bunch of crazy shit all over his
house.
But he had three houses fill this stuff.
The courtyards and all around his pool
was stacked up with shit.
Man,
that's so insane.
It's just
escapism.
This need to sort of like pacify our
existence here.
I just,
you know,
as we kind of evolve and kind of grow
into the future,
it just seems like so few people can
truly be comfortable in their own skin.
And just be,
be present and be comfortable and
content contentness.
We're constantly inventing new ways to
escape,
to disassociate,
to get out of the moment.
What do you think that is?
What do you think is so compelling to us
about the constant accumulation of
material possessions and Ms Dot hold.
Greed is good sort of mentality and
moving up the corporate ladder without
any sort of appreciation or acceptance
and the fact that we're these finite
lifeforms clinging to a spinning orb,
hurling through infinity,
all those inevitable and inescapable
realities.
I mean,
we're,
we,
we look at them every day we look up.
I mean,
that is undeniable that you are looking
up as you leave your house and get to
your car.
You have infinity above your head and
you don't look at it.
I mean,
what,
what's going on with us?
I think,
um,
your were born.
The thing that we've kind of created
this construct that we call society.
We're automatically born into a bad hand
and I think it's,
it's completely bogus.
You're dealt a bad hand at birth.
It doesn't even matter if you're born
into privilege.
I mean,
sure,
that's great.
If you're born into privilege versus the
slums of Mumbai does.
Definitely better.
Yeah,
that's definitely better.
I mean,
of course I'm not going to be falling in
Beverly Hills.
It's way better than Liberia.
Yeah,
I mean Syria,
Bentley convertible.
Did you do in way better than someone in
Zaire with no feet?
No.
No question,
but like,
you know,
you're dealt a bad hand of like,
being alive as hard,
right?
You know,
you're,
you're born,
you're going to go into this building
from ages.
What?
When you go to school,
it just for is that about right?
Some people go to preschool at for
kindergarten is five,
first grade six,
four to 18.
You're going to go into this big cement
building to be taught these certain
subjects in this certain order and then
you're going to leave that cement
building,
go into another one that's even more
expensive and then you're going to leave
that and you're going to get some kind
of employment thing,
which exists pretty much from nine to
five for most people,
unless you're fortunate,
are clever enough to kind of exist
outside of that framework and create
your own reality.
But most people are going to work some
kind of structured life and I just,
I think it's hard.
I think it's just hard to be alive.
It definitely is.
Well,
it's not harder than it's ever been.
It's easier than it's ever been.
Right.
I mean,
it's more safe than it's ever been seen.
Much more access to information than
ever before.
Yes.
But,
you know,
I think it is in some aspects it's
harder because,
um,
well I,
yeah,
I don't know if that's true because back
in the olden times you did have to,
uh,
you know,
kind of compete against each other for
survival.
But I think it could be argued that it's
harder because this constant sort of,
you know,
onslaught of media and comparing
ourselves to each other and to feel
insecure.
If you don't look like that,
if you don't look like this,
if you don't have that,
something's wrong with you.
If you can't afford to buy that,
you're not doing well.
We're fucking up man.
If you can't afford to buy that or if
you don't look like that,
oh my God,
I'm sorry.
Nobody's ever going to want to fuck you.
That's really sad.
I don't want to fuck you if you don't
have the stuff that's awful instead of
all the stuff you've got to have all the
stuff.
And it's a terrible thing to say to
teach our children,
you know?
Well.
So I think it's hard to be alive.
It isn't a sense.
It's very tricky.
And it's also,
I think we are being raised by babies.
I really do think that,
well I have children and I kinda,
I kinda get it now in a sense that
before I had children,
I used to think of people as being sort
of static.
Obviously I was younger and when you're,
especially when you're real young,
when you're like 20 or something like
that,
you don't really take into consideration
that the people around you used to be
your age.
You kind of know it in an abstract sort
of a sense,
but once you actually have a baby and
then like five years later the baby's
talking to you and you're having
conversations,
you're like,
oh,
you're fucking learning shit now,
and then 10 years later they babies in
high school and you're like,
oh Jesus Christ,
you're almost a man.
And then you realize that,
oh,
we're all babies who had babies and you
raise those babies and then they become
adults and have babies of their own,
but no,
there are no grownups.
It's bullshit.
It doesn't exist.
Like when you're a kid and you're sad,
you go,
oh,
one day I'm going to be a grownup and
all this is gonna make sense?
But it never does.
That day never comes you.
You get older,
but you're a baby still.
You're just an old baby.
You're an old baby with a car and
fucking credit card debt and you have a
baby and then that baby grows up.
Well,
I'm smarter than my dad.
He's a fucking idiot.
And it's like,
you know that dad.
My Dad didn't know shit.
He didn't even have the Internet.
It's so funny and you know,
I think that's a.
and I'm not the first to say it,
but that's such a huge thing with trump.
And he acts like a seven year old.
Yeah.
It's like,
what is a seven year old dude?
Like you get your Mug,
Rogan,
you know,
fucking everything
that so truly puts his fucking name on
everybody's probably got it on his socks
and his underwear on the band.
It probably says trump.
Trump underwear.
You were staying at a trump hotel?
Yes.
Yeah,
I know it did in New York.
And you know,
the,
um,
the toilet paper,
I'm like the little sticker they put on
it,
that's an trump insignia on the toilet.
But it is called the trump hotel.
I mean,
if you go to the renaissance,
it says renaissance.
But it's much,
much more ironic though with the trump
thing.
It's weird because it's a guy's name
who's alive and now happens to be
president and he says it's about,
it's a symbol of quality around the
world or whatever the you see that trump
card.
But I think it's bullshit.
I think he's just a seven year old who
likes to write his name on my list.
Shit.
Well the evidence in his tweets to
people you know,
and then he gets mad and tweets about
shit.
He responds to people and argues with
people.
Meet you.
Tweet at him.
No,
no.
I tweeted.
I hardly tweeted anybody.
You don't get it?
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't want to.
I definitely don't get into like those
kind of tweet battles over the Internet.
But I just think as I've gotten older
and had some good experiences and bad
experiences online,
I've realized that you can,
like you were talking about like you go
out and you seek bad things.
If you have this in your mind that
you're going to go out and you're going
to be attacked.
So I'm going to wear a gun.
I'm going to have a knife,
I'm going to wear a bulletproof vest and
all these different things.
Yup.
You can also seek negative interaction
online.
You can go look for it when you find it,
you could react to it and that begets
more of it and I think that you're far
better off just choosing the people that
you interact with an actual real life.
And then when I look at things online,
I'm just observing.
I very rarely interact.
If I do,
it's a very friendly and I limit myself
almost entirely to friendly
interactions.
Cool.
And anything that's negative,
I just stay away.
It's not worth it.
There's nothing to be gained.
If you,
if you get an insult war with somebody
and you make them feel bad,
like do you.
What do you get out of that?
Unless it's funny when you get out of
that,
unless it's tongue and cheek and
everybody's having a good day.
Yeah.
Well and and also you know what you can
do in a hundred and 40 characters is
absolutely ridiculous.
It's insane.
You can't get into a meaningful
thoughtful debate and 140 characters,
but people seek it out.
They seek these debates out and they ask
you like what they think are hard
hitting questions marked.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Get involved in this 140 character
thing.
It's like,
it's not just the reason why I asked
because I'm,
uh,
you know,
Dunkin starting to kind of tweet it,
tweet at trump a little bit and
interest.
Does he,
what does he say?
Just kind of wacky shit like tweets.
Adam,
I'm going to be the minister of,
you know,
whatever you got.
And then we got.
We got to find some of them are there.
They're kind of funny,
but because I think trump sometimes he
does read.
It's reading.
Sweet sort of reads his tweets.
He gets in there.
I guarantee you,
we get to know.
You ever see the debate that he had back
and forth with John Stewart?
Oh yeah,
of course.
I mean that's fucking hilarious.
And Jon Stewart has put it into his act
now.
He tweets them at 1:30 in the morning.
Little Jon Stewart is a pussy and it
would be hopeless in a debate with me.
Imagine that because actually did that.
This is the guy that's the president
now,
so,
so great.
But yeah,
but I mean it says so much about the
personality of someone and I'm,
I,
I don't get in twitter wars because I
don't really tweet all that much.
But get facebook.
Do you use facebook?
I do and I'm just a horribly impulsive
about it.
Horribly impulsive to a fault.
Like what kind of stuff do you get in?
You were saying you have issues with
vegans.
Is that when you get into it?
Yeah,
I mean there's,
there's some vegan stuff,
a lot of politics stuff and you know,
the election cycle and,
and I'm,
I'm,
you know,
a little quick on the trigger to like,
because you know with online,
in social media it's just push a button
and like,
you know,
calling people more on just far too
quickly for taking a breath,
stepping back and go,
maybe I shouldn't call you a moron.
That's probably not the best debate
tactic,
you know,
benefit it,
that benefit if you make them feel bad
that there are more on and you get your
rocks off in some way.
And I've done it.
I absolutely have done in the past,
but I don't,
I try very hard not to engage in that
kind of thinking anymore because I don't
think all it does not going to like it.
Also,
when you get into conflicts with people,
negative conflicts create these uh,
centers of attention and those conflicts
become these centers of attention and
ultimately nothing happens in them.
They just sort of distract you.
A little vortex of bullshit.
And I think and as I've gotten older and
started analyzing my own life and
happiness and productivity and when I'm
at my most creative is when I'm not
engaging in any of that,
like the least.
I am involved in the negativity and
conflicts and debates and going back and
forth and trying to make people feel bad
and all that stupid shit that people
getting wrapped up in you fucking idiot.
You know,
all that kind of stupid stuff.
But more the least.
I do that the more it frees up my
resources and it frees up my mind and I
don't have this,
like I think anytime you get in conflict
a content conflict with someone,
it creates like this negative center,
this like there's this vortex.
It's like weird area in your mind,
in your consciousness where that
conflict exists.
It's on a shelf just stinking up the
joint and I think the least amount of
those that you have in your
consciousness and your library of,
of memories,
the better off you are.
Yeah,
I tend to.
I tend to agree with that and I tend to
feel that like,
you know,
especially if it's for somebody of my
cloth,
it's hyper hypocritical to attack
online,
you know,
over their political beliefs for sure.
Um,
you know,
being a spiritual person,
but I'm not at the same time like
especially now within the last year,
this is a highly charged debate cycle
and I was convinced that,
you know,
how,
how possible,
how could a cognitive Lee kind of adept
human being justify voting for Donald
Trump?
Like,
it just didn't make sense to me,
but it happened one volv justify voting
for hillary either.
Oh,
I can make that.
Kenya.
Absolutely don't you think that there's
a lot of issues involved with Hillary
Clinton?
First of all,
Hillary said in the wikileaks documents
that she was against marijuana
legalization,
legalization in every sense of the word.
I,
I'm,
I'm not,
you know,
Pro Hillary Foundation.
I mean,
there's a lot of things you could bring
up.
I'm not a Clinton flag waving kind of
guy,
but you know,
comparing the two,
you know,
and,
and like however you look like.
So to me Hillary Clinton was just status
quo,
right?
But it isn't the status quo fucked up
and yet really the status quo is better
than negative,
right?
This is going to be negative progress.
And how negative,
how certain are you that it's going to
be negative progress?
Absolutely certain.
I mean the Supreme Court alone,
I mean,
you know,
Ginsburg made the fatal flaw of not
retiring sooner.
So I mean she's 180 years old.
So there's already,
there's already one vacancy there.
Environments,
man,
she's not gonna make it.
And you know,
so trump in one term could presumably
have three appointees.
Right?
And that is negative progress,
but you know,
that he was a Democrat for almost.
No,
but he's not now man.
I mean,
look,
Steve Bannon and the CEO of Exxon,
the CEO of Carl's Jr.
I'm a ben carson and being the hud guy.
But I mean it's,
it's just,
it's absolute insanity.
Why didn't he make Ben Carson,
carson,
the attorney general,
or rather the,
uh,
surgeon general surgeon general.
I mean,
why wouldn't he have been involved in
something medical?
I mean,
he's very talented.
Neurospheres jesse was tHe african
american guy who grew up in the projects
man.
So he should run hud.
Oh,
how odd.
That was the argument.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
that was,
it seems like he knows more aBout
medIcine,
right.
As a doctor take you to fucking medical
expert.
And he's actually good at that.
Yeah,
he's fucking amazing at it.
I mean,
he's like one of the top neurosurgeons
in the world.
Right.
So he grew up from the projects.
African american guy grew up out of
there.
So he must know about the housing and
urban development.
So it's just complete insanity to me.
Ended is taking two,
three steps backwards,
the only silver lining that you can
weave from it and it is,
you know,
it's a good thing to weave is that there
is kind of a collective,
a consolidation
of solidarity,
kind of like,
hey,
you know,
we need to rise up,
get our shit together,
figure out how to articulate the
opposite vision and perhaps defeat this
later on down the line.
And that's cool.
People are waking up and there's great
conversations happening.
Well I think there's an ebb and flow
that always exists in cultures.
You know,
there's a push left and a push,
right?
And we try this for eight years and then
we'd go that way for eight years and
some of it's productive and some of it's
very negative,
but even the negative,
ultimately it,
it,
it fosters resistance and that
resistance is often times positive.
And in even in resistance,
there's a lot of understanding of the
consequences of negativity that may be
wasn't really appreciate it.
And while you had like a progressive
democrat in office,
but then there's,
you know,
there's things that obama did that
people are incredibly upset with in
terms of whistle blowing,
you know,
like whistleblowers were supposed to be
cherished and he was going to help him.
That was all part of the hope and change
website when he was running for
president as was.
And then of course he's been one of the
worst people in terms of freedom of
press in terms of whistleblowers been in
one of the worst administrations ever.
Guantanamo never closed drones.
Yeah.
Drones and drone wars.
All this stuff because there's
absolutely no,
there's some,
there's no doubt about it.
Um,
but you know,
with sort of,
you know,
the ebbs and flows of progress versus no
progress,
you know.
And in this instance,
in this context,
it's just how many people are going to
get hurt as a result of it.
That's like,
that's what I don't mind.
That's why it's not the lack of
perspective that I think we have
collectively as a culture.
The lack of.
I mean what you were talking about about
these people living their lives solely
intent on acquiring material possessions
and status and all the nonsense that
goes with it.
How much of that can be attributed to
the relative lack of exposure to
psychedelics collectively that we have.
If you looked at,
if you looked at the entire 300 million,
but you knoW how they do that red map
and you see how many people are
republicans and how many people are
democrats and it looks like a.
It looks like the whole country,
one of the avatar people get hit by a
train and that's what it looks like.
Right?
I got splattered.
But when you.
When you look at that,
if you had a similar map in terms of
like how many people have had what I
would consider a Breakthrough
psychedelic experienCe.
I know some people that have done
mushrooms and they did a little bit and
they felt good and no big deal and I.
I had done quite a few things before my
first real dmt trip and the first real
real dmt trip was like,
okay,
everything else is bullshit.
Like,
this is awesome,
this is so awesome,
and so mind blowing and just knowing
that that's a real plaCe that anyone can
get to.
relatively easy.
Not only that,
this is not a precious material.
this is a material that exists in
thousands of different plants all over
you.
Everywhere you go.
Like every drive down the street,
you'll a fucking hundred different kinds
of plants that have dnt in around.
So the dmt experience to me was a.
I would say like I was really like two
different people on the pre dmt person
in the post emt person.
I'm like,
I mean a real similar.
I talked to the same but the,
the person,
the experiences,
they're so vastly different that I was
exposed to a whole new infinity area of
the spectrum that I didn't know existed
before.
I assisted in this very small area.
I thought there was like birth and death
and love and sex and beer and you know,
fucking movies and what all the other
things he enjoyed.
Right.
I didn't even know that was real.
How many people out there like that?
I mean,
is there a,
a million of us,
I mean,
is there even,
is there even 2 million?
I mean,
how many people out of the 300 and
whatever million people in this country
have had breakthrough psychedelic
experiences?
How many people did they say did lsd in
the sixties?
It's a good question.
That changed the culture.
I don't know what the number is,
but I mean,
you had your dad's on around.
I probably tell us.
Yeah,
it was probably responsible for 40 or 50
percent of it.
Right?
What was the number?
It was.
Yeah.
And this is,
to me,
this is a fascinating case study for us
to look at is,
you know,
in the sixties,
millions and millions and millions of
people did some kind of psychedelic,
right?
Yeah.
And if they didn't do a second alec,
at least they,
you know,
smoked grass and put on sergeant peppers
at the very least.
And yay,
great thIngs were born out of that.
I mean,
an argument could be made that if the
sixties didn't happen and flourish and
become what it became that you and I
wouldn't be some here right now and
being able to talk about what we're
talking about.
I think that's a very good argument.
I think.
Yeah,
right.
but here we are 2016 and Donald Trump is
elected president.
So last time we had a global kind of
consciousness shift that was massive and
really shook us all up,
you know,
I don't know,
not enough happened.
So it's like,
what's it going to take next time?
Okay.
So let's,
let's get,
let's just say let's get 10 percent of
the country to turn on.
And for me I kind of,
I'm a little bit more elastic with it
and I think that can also be,
you know,
meditation.
Sure.
Or,
or flickr,
flotation tanks.
Not so holotropic breathing,
whatever.
The method isn't as important to me
anymore,
but like say get 10 to 20 percent of the
people to do that.
Six,
three,
6 million people,
whatever it is,
you know,
then you know,
what,
what is it going to change?
How are we going to integrate,
and we'd,
we're talking about this a couple of
hours ago,
it's like the integration part and I
think perhaps that's what we lost in the
sixties.
We were so hung up on the veil getting
pierced and in my dad's,
one of the best quotes is um,
in order to understand the sixties,
you must understand the fifties,
right?
What a change in the fifties were just,
you know,
very lock and step and white picket
fence,
two point five children,
cart,
you know,
suit and tie,
hair short.
Like there was no variation.
And we burst that bubble.
But even at the integration level,
it just wasn't,
wasn't media enough,
you know,
we still,
we elected Richard Nixon in 1968.
I mean,
granted Robert Kennedy was shot,
but still,
you know,
and here we are 50 years later and look
what we're doing.
So,
you know,
it is great to turn on and I liked
people turning on and I think it's
fantastic and it's a great thing to talk
about like you are in it,
you know,
you have a huge megaphone and getting
people to do that.
But what are they going to do different?
That's what I'm more concerned with.
They're going to consider their life in
a different way.
And I think that yeah,
that in many people maybe,
maybe not at all of us,
but in many people that changes the
direction of the path that you're on.
It changes the way you communicate with
people,
changes your understanding of each other
in your understanding of the connections
that we have with each other.
yes.
Um,
I think there's a giant chunk of people
that are what you would call a
influencers in this country,
whether it's politicians or ceos of
large corporations casters.
Well,
I mean,
I'm just going to say people that
haven't had this experience,
these,
these influencers that live in this,
a very flat plane of existence,
of acquiring material possessions,
getting your dick sucked,
doing a line of coke,
driving in your limo,
all the different shit that a lot of
people like look forward to that like
ultimately might not really be important
or important.
It might feel importaNt in the moment,
you know,
and this ego gratification sort of a
way,
but without that ego obliterating
experience to put it all into
perspective,
you might not understand that that state
of mind is even achievable.
Like the undeniable ego shattering
experience of like a severe mushroom
trip or a dmt trip or you know,
any,
anything along those lines.
It's so beneficial in that it gives you
that momentary break from the ego and
from this mo,
the momentum of the race that you might
not really want to be in.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of people that are doing
things they fucking hate all day long
Just in order to acquire shit that they
don't really need.
Yeah man.
And that's what I was like,
the point I was trying to make earlier
is like this hand that you're deAlt is
bunk because you're like so many people
are trapped in that thing of like doing
something they hate.
right.
But do they have to be like.
It sounds like
they think they have to be.
That's what I'm talking about.
They think they have to be,
but no they don't.
They can breAk free.
They can pierce the veil.
They can go into a dmt trip or gotten a
flotation take and break free and then
even just by quitting some fucking
shitty job and doing something you love
it.
Why don't more people do that because
they're scared.
Is that what is 100 percent?
Yeah.
People are afraid of change.
They're afraid of the unknown.
They're afraid of uncertainty.
They're afraid of failure for sure.
If you offer them some really
convenient,
stupid job that is absolutely
going to stay there for them.
Or hey man,
take a chance to open a pottery studio,
I'm going to go broke.
People are terrified of failure.
Yeah,
I mean I think you're right,
but I also think there's a level of it
that's also kind of like graduate school
in the sense that maybe a lot of people
are just addicted to being pacified that
like,
you know,
I get my three hours of television that
night and I get my,
you know,
and they're even considering that notion
of what you're talking about beyond the
realm.
Well,
you know,
that experience keep me plugged in.
I'm cool.
You know,
that expreSsion,
the comfort zone is beautiful,
but nothing grows there.
uh,
it's,
it,
it's a great,
you know,
it's nice to be comfortable.
It's beautiful,
relaxed,
but you don't get better at anything.
You don't get better at life,
you don't grow.
And we're scared of uncertainty.
Now we want to survive.
We don't want to starve to death.
We don't want to be a failure.
We don't want to be that guy that used
to be on tv and now he's a security
guard,
you know?
Then all those things that like the fear
of not being successful,
so stifling it.
GOt it.
It's so,
isn't it?
When you say that,
who just immediately just triggered my,
you know,
my own life and all the failures.
I've had all the fuck ups falling flat
on my face,
you know,
many,
many times.
BuT like getting back up,
it's like that's where the work is,
that's where the,
that's where the awakening is.
I mean,
it wasn't like,
hey,
everything is going perfectly and oh
well isn't this all my life?
And since rolling out on a red carpet
and then I turned on or something
happened and I touched the face of
enlightenment.
NO,
it's because I fell in the dirt and you
take those risks and shit happens and
you and you,
the grist for the mill is wronged us
would say.
And you know,
you have that grist for the mill that
makes it so much jucier and falling
funding your face.
It's essential.
And I think essential You can apply that
same sort of thinking to our entire
civilization.
And I think right now we might've
skinned our knees.
We might've fallen on our face,
we might've gone facedown in the mud.
and I'm like,
oh fuck.
And I think you've got to get up and
realize that we fucked it up.
You know?
and we'll see how bad we fucked it up.
And who knows.
Because one of the things about having
an outsider in this,
what I think is an impossibly corrupt
unfixable foundation filled with
bullshit,
which is what I think our society is
built on.
Whether it's special interest groups,
corporate greed or lobbyists or all the
chaos,
private prisons.
And fucking the war on drugs,
all the chaos that I think any rational
person that's not connected to it in any
sort of a way where you're making profit
off of would agree like this is an
insane way for an enlightened society to
behave and act.
It's broken,
right?
Unfixable.
Just just bullshit,
right?
That the awareness of that is more and
more exposed today online and in
conversations and people are more aware
of that than any other time in human
history.
But I feel like we're like
a giant battleship,
but it takes a lot to turn that fucker.
It takes on a lot of,
a lot of thinking and action.
It takes a long time for that thing to
actually spin around.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
And the first,
you know,
the first step in that is like the
acknowledgement that hey,
we skinned our knees or maybe fell flat
face down into the mode or something.
And is the acknowledgement that that is
the case.
That's the scenario we're in.
And which is why I'm always so
frustrated in that like,
you know,
the general narrative or the general
rhetoric,
especially in politics is,
you know,
the wrong conversations always being
had.
Nobody's talking about the right shit.
We're treating the symptom.
We never treat the disease.
We're just treating the flu,
you know,
blowing her notes constantly and never,
ever acknowledging the disease.
You know,
bernie,
bernie sanders touched on acknowledging
the disease.
He was the first guy.
WhAt really in a long time to make it
that far and acknowledged the disease.
We are at risk of becoming an oligarchy.
It's the top one percent that is ruling
the country.
He may be the first guy ever.
Right?
I mean if you really stop and think
about it,
like who got that close to the
democratic nomination,
the.
Yeah.
Other than mcgovern.
But I mean,
I think in know older,
older times,
you know,
in the 19th century there was kind of,
hints that this could happen and kind of
people in senior waiting a,
hey,
the industrial revolution and carnegies
and the mellons and the rockefellers.
Like,
watch out that this could get dangerous.
Uh,
eisenhower warned of the military
industrial complex.
I think it was a republican.
Um,
and that was a creepy speech,
right?
They're creepy speech but fascinating at
the same time.
But yeAh.
So.
But bernie took it.
He did talk about the disease,
which was fantastic.
So it is out there that you know,
that we have these fundamental problems
until you fix the fundamental problem,
nothing else is going to get better,
which is essentially taking the money
out of the game.
Yeah,
right.
Well,
that's what I do think it's fixable.
I disagree with you in that,
that I do think the machine is,
it's fixable.
How it fixable.
Take the money out.
That's unfixable.
No,
it's the whole thing runs on money.
How are you going to take the money out?
Have you read?
Um,
republic last,
the lawrence lessig book?
No,
you gotta read it,
man.
Fascinating.
Was this solution or watched his twentY
minute ted talk.
You can get the whole book and that was
the solution.
Get rid of lobbyists.
Yeah,
man,
that's easier said than done.
I know,
I know.
Some of my trump is actually working to
do that,
whereas someone like hillary is not
like,
he's already put in a bunch of
regulations to make sure that people
cannot become lobbyists,
but at a certain amount of time after
leaving off after leaving office.
But he also has like the prisoner elect
office is crawling at the same time.
It's crawling with lobbyists.
Yeah.
Who knows?
You know,
I mean,
I'm not a trump supporter,
but I'm not.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm not.
I'm not convinced that having this
complete outsider who's also a guy who's
been feeding this machine with money and
making these massive political
contributions so he understands the
system and how works.
I'm
not completely,
I'm not completely denying the
possibility that he might present some
good.
I just think he's the wrong guy for the
job.
I do believe in the outsider thing.
I love that.
That's great.
That's a great part of him.
I just,
bernie would have been fascinating.
Bernie would have been fascinated.
Costs me a shitload of money,
but I would have been willing to take
that chance.
I would loved to see it.
I love to see what the fuck would happen
because that guy doesn't give a shit and
he's not.
You can't buy him,
man.
He can't buy him in and you've got to
watch this,
this lawrence lessig tuck.
It's a few years old now,
but it really just,
it kind of rips apart and puts
everything out on the whiteboard and
into a,
like a keynote presentation about even
the,
you know,
the most well intentioned to politicians
who are great.
Mr. Smith goes to Washington kind of
shit.
Just great people who go in there with
the best of intentions,
you know,
at some point,
you know.
Then they end up spending 25 percent of
their time inside of the phone bank,
the democratic,
the dnc phone bank,
begging people for money and I know they
do that and it's across the street from
the capital so it's not too far and it
just ended escalates and it's a
snowball.
Just go more and more and then it just
becomes even the best intent.
It just out of politics.
Then you have only people with money who
get into politics because they have so
much money.
They don't need anybody else's money.
Hence Donald Trump.
Yeah,
but I mean if you did it like a,
you know,
first of all,
if you did it like the uk,
does it shortened the election season.
You know,
first we got,
that's a great first step.
You know,
you can't make it 18 months.
It's insane.
And the amount of money,
team sport,
it's going on forever.
We get a root root,
rah rah.
They got debates and the season.
Yeah man.
Great television people where they're
reading,
they're fucking blue and make America
great again.
Hats or the amount of money that it
takes to play that.
I know,
right?
What we seen making per day.
I'll make America great again.
I bet millions now.
He was making like 80 grand a day or
something.
Something stupid.
It's so bad.
It's those stupid looking ads too.
They're not.
It's not even a good design.
It's like somebody made it at the mall,
you know those little hat shops.
Would you want it to say bobby loves
jesse.
All right,
love jesse.
Make America great again.
Hat white letters.
I'm the man.
I'm the fucking man.
I got the hat on fucking man.
I don't even know what that means.
Yeah,
he doesn't know what it means either.
Well,
I don't know.
I mean,
America has never been greater in terms
of like be safer,
more access to medicine,
more access to information,
more access to education.
That's never been better in that way.
But like,
uh,
you know,
who are the rent our education rankings,
it's sort of in the world in a world
where we're used to place,
you know,
the typical high school graduate
graduate in the year,
like 1960,
you know,
it's like going to college and brent and
ranked number one in global math,
science,
you know,
that's because the rest of the world was
in the stone age and we were uh,
we were the only civilization I think.
I think we were,
we had just started
civilization back then and no one knew
about it yet.
And they all caught on and we got fat
off twinkies and the mall and fucking
walmart poisoned us.
And then thIs shit from fracking that
definitely got into the wall.
I don't know,
man.
I think everyone on,
I'm fine with that too.
I'm a pessimist in some,
in some forms,
but I'm an optimist and others and what
I'm optimistic about is that people care
and that this,
this world that we live in,
that this is a,
you know,
like when everybody was crying after
trump got elected and part of me was
like,
well this is so preposterous,
like why these people crying?
But the other part of me was like,
that is when things get done is when you
have this outpouring of emotion and then
people you know,
like remember when those people were
marching down wilshire and it was just
fucking huge line of people,
like hundreds of thousand people that
shut down wilshire and these people
filming it with drones from overhead.
I was like,
wow,
that's a crazy response to this guy
winning the presidency.
And the people were like hoping the
electors,
you know,
the electoral college people wouldn't
elect him and they were,
they would act on their fuck you.
It's not gonna happen like you'Re
playing a game.
he won the game and you can't,
you can't take it away from him.
After he won the game,
like he didn't cheat,
he won the game.
So this is the game and this is how the
game works.
Russia,
listen to this is the game is how the
game works.
Now you've got to figure out why is this
game in place?
Why do you have this fucking goofy game?
Why do you have this representative
government?
Why?
Why do we continue this?
You know,
and if we can slowly move that
battleship and towards a more rational
place.
Yeah,
you're right.
And it does come from a consciousness
shift.
That's the first step.
Always comes from a consciousness shift.
I think pot,
I think legal pot,
real gateway.
I really do.
I really do because I think it calms
people down.
It makes people nicer and I think just
that alone,
it's like the opposite of what alcohol
does.
that's true.
It's definitely does not increAse in
aggression or for confidence.
It doesn't increase confidence At all.
It's the opposite for me.
It makes me.
That's why I don't smoke.
The more vulnerable,
you don't smoke it.
I like it.
Don't like something changed in me.
I did when I was at duke when I was a
teenager,
like loved it,
man,
when my dad had and that was my life,
but you know,
I take it now and it's just paranoia,
massive.
And also the confidence thing.
It does not bring out my best.
It makes me feel like if we smoked and
we did this podcast,
so be freaking out and I have to say to
sound like an idiot,
don't get told me I wouldn't be like
that.
So it just does not bring up my best.
So how long ago is this switch?
When did it happen to you?
Quite a while.
I mean,
I'm 43,
you know,
no more than 15 years ago.
So that's when you stopped smoking 15
years ago.
I stopped yesterday.
I'm Still freaking because he
yesterday's but
yeah,
about that.
Yeah.
So,
um,
what,
do you do anything these days?
Not so to psychedelics or.
No,
not really.
No I don't,
but um,
yeah,
I keep a place in my heart for the
psychedelic experience.
Should it arise again,
um,
you know,
in between english monthly in between
the egg and um,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
I mean I'm,
I'm open to that and should the
opportunity arise,
I'm down for it.
Um,
I mean with the psychedelic thing,
I just,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
I am open to it.
I just,
I kind of did kind of hit the Alan Watts
wall in a way like,
you know,
the Alan Watts thing about,
um,
uh,
you know,
I got the phone call and then I learned
to hang up the phone.
What does Alan Watts thing,
how's that work as the quote goes?
Something like,
um,
I got the phone call and then I kind of
learned to hang up the phone.
I didn't need to stay on the phone with
me.
It's like,
oh,
I see,
I see.
So you got the message.
He got the message to continually get
the message over and over and over and
over again.
Mckenna,
I think was in that boat too.
Before his death,
they were saying that he talked a lot
about it,
but he really wasn't doing anything
anymore.
Oh really?
Oh,
I didn't know that he smoked a lot of
pot though.
Did smoke a little pot because I always
remember it,
terrence,
you know,
the thing that struck people have his
room
pete ability is that.
Well it's true,
but I know it's tough to have 5,000
fucking mushroom trips and with jesus
christ,
I mean I've done acid what 200 times or
something you could probably see like
legally insane.
Right?
I don't think.
I think like there'S a certain amount of
acid trips you do where they used to
classify you as being legally insane.
Yeah.
I mean maybe you get some money from the
government,
bro.
You hook it up much.
Probably 50 bucks.
I don't know
if he just ran around saying that I
broke my brain and I'm disabled.
I bet you could email the system.
I use that.
It's really funny.
You know,
I had um,
it reminds me,
I used to have a pretty serious hard
drug problem to which hard drugs.
Yeah.
Which I,
I've gotten,
you know,
which one's a heroin and crack and oh
damn.
Gotten through it.
The needle or the smart starting
smoking.
Smoking the needles.
No needles.
Yeah.
Stayed away from that,
but you know,
made it through and I'm good.
How'd you get on that?
How to get on it?
Um,
oh,
pain.
He had some injuries or something.
No pain.
Emotional pain,
emotional pain,
emotional suffering,
pain.
Last aimless wandering the world,
aimless.
Not knowing what to do.
And that was the escape was the heroine.
Somebody introduced me to it about that
period in time and it just was like,
oh wow.
You know,
heroin has the great ability of um,
and it's really seductive and really
fucked up of making you think that your
life is okay when you're in the gutter.
Wow.
It has that sort of,
that shooting that it just kind of
bubble it puts over you.
You can be literally living in an
alleyway.
Highend heroin thinking you got it going
on.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's really weird and perverse like
that.
And at that time in my life.
YEah.
I mean,
my dad just died.
Um,
and you know,
when he died,
what with it,
what went with it was kind of my life up
until I was 22 up until that point.
Like,
my life was in that bubble,
you know,
he was larger than life.
He was famous,
you know,
girls came with that work,
came with that scene,
came with that,
friends came with that and when he died
that just went poof.
Girls want to bang you because you were.
Oh,
of course.
The leary course.
Yeah.
Really nice.
It worked out for awhile.
Did you put on like a guru attitude?
Like,
oh god laughs,
I've got it all going on ladies at that
time,
that,
that stage in my life now it's a
disaster.
And I tried to do that now though on
occasion.
Oh.
But no,
I had a good story man.
So it's really funny,
like you were talking about soliciting
the government for money for being an
acid casualties,
which is a good idea.
But I was really high on crack once,
um,
and just kind of on a bender,
just losing my mind and crack.
And I thought in the middle of the
night,
be a really good idea to join the cia
and that they would want me,
me specifically being like tim leary's
kit,
they'd want me because I have access to
shit that they want access to.
Like I can be an insight.
I was a mole and it was high on crack
and I downloaded.
I filled out the form that deep.
I got that deep.
I spent hours on it.
It's really long.
Complicated though.
The whole kind of joined the cia,
printed out,
sent it in the mail.
you're in the cia,
you there with anderson cooper and he
worked for cnn and you're in there and
never heard back.
But I never heard back.
Never,
never seen laughing,
but he just laughed and threw it in the
garbage and shirt.
But it was really funny and kind of a
great delusional high on drugs moment.
Wow.
So what did you think that you were
going to do?
Like as a operative going to do it.
You have to fix it from the inside with
crack
like that.
Wow.
Something crazy,
you know,
just that's what a crackhead does.
How did you get another crack in the
heroin?
Um,
yeah,
just recovery.
Did you go the 12 step away or narcotics
anonymous?
That kind of stuff?
Yeah,
worked for me.
How does,
now,
is that one of those things you have to
continually visit?
Do you have to constantly have meetings
and stuff?
Um,
well,
you know,
I'm kind of a,
I'm kind of in a way as a card carrying
members where I'm kind of not the best
card carrying member of it and I break
from tradition and a little bit in that
like,
I don't know,
I'm not a zealot.
Sure.
Maybe.
Um,
yeah.
Maybe you do,
but for me I just happened to like it.
I just enjoy it.
Whether or not I have to go and all my
god,
I'm gonna die.
If I don't know I'm gonna end up back in
the gutter of.
I don't.
I
don't know.
I believe there's a little hysteria with
that and that's kind of like the party
line,
which sometimes bothers me.
It bothers a lot of people,
sort of disempowerment,
disempowerment.
I don't believe that to any with any
tradition or anything like,
oh my god,
if you leave us the shit's gonna hit the
fan.
I mean,
you stop and think about a lot of
destructive things you did when you were
younger that you don't do now.
Well,
I don't need a 12 step program to tell
me not to do stupid shit.
Yeah.
I just,
I just know it's stupid shit and so I
don't do it anymore.
But the idea that you could potentially
fall into that is what they hold over
your head,
but it's not that simple.
Like,
oh my god,
I know heroin was going to kill me,
so I'm just.
I'm just going to stop doing it.
It's not that rational.
Sadly.
I wish it was that difference.
What's the disconnect?
The disconnect is that in order to bill
wilson was really a groundbreaking dude.
Well,
he was also an acid head,
which is really kind of crazy.
Bill wilson being the guy who founded
alcoholics anonymous five times.
He also thought that acid could be a
viable treatment method for people that
are alcoholics.
It's completely ignored today and his
thoughts and ideas about that completely
ignored by people in recovery because
they think that no,
no,
no.
You don't get get cleaned by taking
something else.
They hate it.
Yeah.
And I before,
um,
you know,
that sort of got popular and before the
documentary came out and all that about
exposing bill wilson,
I used it to,
below,
you know,
a member's minds with that to do not.
He did it and he had correspondence with
my dad when he was at harvard.
I'm sure he did.
I had some really interesting.
These letters are fantastic.
Um,
and um,
yeah,
he called it the great egos sublimate
her and thought it could be the solution
for alcoholism and he did not change his
sobriety date,
which is highly controversial.
Sobriety date,
friday date.
Like when he said he got sober,
he still,
when he died,
he said he had whatever 48 years sober,
but he was still doing acid when he had
stopped doing acid.
But typically,
you know,
in the,
in a world if you do asset,
that's it.
You start over,
you start day one and day one.
But he didn't,
he did not.
I looked at acid has been completely
different than an intoxicant like
alcohol.
It was a neuro psychotropic therapeutic
agent you referred to.
Well,
I think that is what it is.
And I think this blanket statement,
you know,
drugs that word drugs,
it's just like,
it's,
it applies to too many things to do too
many different things.
That's right.
It's like food,
you know,
food is bad for you.
why?
No,
no foods not bad for you.
Well this food is bad for you.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
It is.
But like the salads.
Good for you.
Like that's food too.
And that's the problem with drugs.
Drugs,
the word drugs applies to things that
are highly beneficial.
That's right.
It's just,
you know,
in,
in a land,
I get why they need to tell her that
that company line.
But I do get it because again,
it's disempowering in a way,
isn't it?
Because it's,
you're treating everybody as
if you are the weakest possible
examples.
It.
Look man,
I'm not,
I'm not disagreeing with you at all,
but I'm just saying I get it because it
does work.
Right.
That's all I can say about it and I
don't disagree with I'm,
I'm kind of wishy washy about it,
but it works.
I just have a hard line.
I have seen people's lives who you just
went,
you know,
the,
the doldrums,
you know,
the disinfect,
I mean,
left for dead,
get their life saved and have really
great productive,
amazing life today.
And it's a really beautiful,
cool thing to see.
But this all sides,
you know,
we,
we have to come to the realization that
everyone's different.
Biological.
Yes.
That,
that's why that that's the point.
Everybody's wired differently.
There is no one size fits all thing.
And,
and now what we're seeing with ibogaine
treatment,
that map system,
oh my god.
So,
so cool.
Really,
really,
really promising.
And so,
you know,
I just encourage everybody to find their
own dharma,
find their own path and you kind of make
what works for you.
You know,
there's no prescribed method for
spiritual awakening or life saving or
life changing,
you know,
you just have to,
balance it correctly.
So listen to your heart,
what is your life like?
Like what do you,
what do you do with your time?
What do you do for money?
I do a few things.
I am.
My life is kind of split into two things
I have in my podcast.
What is that called again?
It's all happening.
Yeah.
Um,
and so I do that.
I'm,
I'm actually starting another podcast.
I'm going to be hosting the maps
podcast.
Oh really?
Oh,
that's awesome.
So maps is going to help them get off
the ground and host it and start that.
Um,
so,
you know,
I kind of do that.
I can speak or you know,
at festivals and kind of teach,
you know,
some,
some spiritual stuff and kind of do
that.
Right.
I've been working on the book,
but the other half of my life,
I'm kind of before I had my own little
spiritual awakening.
I was a technology consultant in the
branding consultant and worked in
digital marketing and at a lot of ad
agencies and stuff and they'd kind of a
nine to five corporate life,
which I,
I've ditched.
But um,
I still keep some clients as kind of a
day job sort of thing,
which is of fun.
That's interesting.
So like what,
what does that entail as far as anything
that is,
if,
you know,
if a brand or an entity or a film or a
music client,
anybody wants to come to me and sort of
define their internet strategy,
how they want to behave online,
um,
whether that's just something as mundane
as having a new website to coming up
with a complete communication message
about how they want to market their,
their thing.
So I kind of do that too.
So I divide my time sort of 50 slash 50
between my stuff and then other
people's.
And when is this map's podcast launch?
January.
Oh,
that's cool.
So you,
you'll buy just by having that name
attached to it,
you'll be able to get some pretty
amazing guests.
YeAh,
man,
we'd love you to do it.
Of course.
Yeah.
That's good.
Sign it up.
Yeah.
Rick dunn to set it up fast.
So yeah,
2017 folks.
Shit's going down.
So I keeP busy,
man.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
All right man.
Well,
um,
let people know what's your twitter
handle?
Is it just zach leering,
zach,
larry,
or go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com.
and the podcast is called.
It's all happening.
Is it available on itunes podcast stuff?
Yeah.
Well,
thanks man.
Thanks for coming in.
Thank you very much.
Zackly relays,
gentlemen.
Thank you everybody.
We'll be back tomorrow with the great
greg fitzsimmons,
also known as grapefruit simmons.